bien chers collègues chers invités je
tiens à vous saluer toutes et tous
saluer particulièrement la rapporteur la
sénatrice Florence la Sarrade pour cette
matinée sur les conséquences du
réchauffement climatique sur la
biodiversité
des travaux
qui font longue date maintenant au sein
de l'Office parlementaire d'évaluation
des choix scientifiques et
technologiques avec notamment un certain
nombre de séries de notre scientifiques
qui sont en cours d'élaboration ou qui
ont été publiés jusqu'à présent et
évidemment nous sommes heureux
d'accueillir je laisserai la rapporteur
présenté l'ensemble des intervenants de
la matinée
d'accueillir la communauté scientifique
depuis plus d'une vingtaine d'années
maintenant les effets du réchauffement
climatique sur la biodiversité sont des
objets qui sont bien connus et qui font
consensus au sein de la communauté
scientifique
d'ailleurs dans un ouvrage paru cette
année Hervé letreux qui a participé pour
notre pays aux travaux du GIEC remarque
que l'expertise considérable dont nous
disposons en France dans les
laboratoires et institutions publiques
peines parfois à être sollicité de
manière cohérente
je pense que c'est important de pouvoir
avoir ce matin cette audition pour
donner aussi de l'épaisseur de la
cohérence et aussi un cap
au-delà scientifique un cap évidemment
politique sur sur ces enjeux qui ne
manqueront pas évidemment
d'intéresser l'ensemble des collègues
qui sont présents je vais pas être plus
bavard nous avons une belle matinée
devant nous peut-être je voudrais
laisser la parole
non au premier vice-président bon ben
écoutez dans ce cas là je cède la parole
à la reporter
merci monsieur le Président d'abord je
tenais à remercier nos intervenants
malgré ces grèves
d'aujourd'hui d'avoir réussi à arriver
jusqu'au Sénat
il y a un bon et un petit moment
maintenant et je vais présenter les
trois intervenants dont un sera en visio
Monsieur Philippe grandcolac qui est
spécialiste de systématique au Muséum
alors que nous sommes habitués au grand
tableau des espèces suspendus dans nos
écoles où nous étions peut-être pour ma
génération habitué à ça il est peut-être
intéressant de se demander comment
concevoir et représenter une
biodiversité qui est pourtant en
perpétuel évolution vous êtes déclaré
prêt à résoudre ce paradoxe apparent
nous entendrons aussi madame
Anne-Christine Monnet qui est chercheuse
au Muséum qui apportera peut-être une
autre plus optimiste en s'évaluant en
s'efforçant d'évaluer les actions de
conservation telles que la production
d'espèces menacées ou la constitution de
réseau d'air protégés dans ce contexte
de changement climatique et on visio
nous accompagne monsieur Wolfgang Kramer
qui est directeur de recherche à
l'Institut de méditerranéen de
biodiversité d'écologie marine et
continentale avec son Provence et qui
nous fera pas de son expérience demande
du GIEC pour évoquer le réchauffement
comme menace prospective sur la
biodiversité
monsieur Grandcolas si vous voulez
commencer nous vous écoutons avec
attention merci merci beaucoup merci
pour cette invitation mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs donc comme vous
l'avez dit en fait j'essaye de résoudre
un paradoxe en fait si on part de la
biodiversité on en a souvent un constat
un peu d'apparence immédiate un peu
comme les aiguilles d'une montre comme
on peut regarder qui ne semble pas
bouger et puis si on les fixe à nouveau
quelques minutes après on s'aperçoit
qu'elles ont effectivement changé de
position alors là toute la question
aujourd'hui c'est de savoir à quelle
vitesse ces aiguilles bougent et de
quelle manière nous pouvons en fait
résoudre ce paradoxe de manière à savoir
comment notre environnement et la
diversité des vivants qui s'y trouve
peuvent évoluer en regard du changement
plus global et notamment du changement
du climat
alors si je peux peut-être obtenir la
mode projection ça me permettra de
passer la diapositive
si vous avez si vous pouvez enclencher
le mode projection du de la diapositive
cliquez sur la petite icône qui se
trouve en bas à droite du tableau juste
à côté de la barre d'échelle
bon on verra je crains qu'on ne voit pas
les diapositives à ce moment-là
ce que je peux me permettre de me
déplacer pour vous
je crains que ça reste un peu dans cette
situation
on va essayer de faire malgré tout
peut-être si vous pouvez réduire la
taille de la diapool de manière qu'on la
voit dans sa totalité
voilà voilà
je vous remercie donc en fait le constat
de la diversité du vivant c'est un
constat qui a été conduit à partir de
des années 80 dans lequel on s'est rendu
compte que nos connaissances sur le
vivant étaient connaissances en général
qui étaient basées sur des organismes
étudiés au laboratoire sur l'espèce
humaine on s'est rendu compte à la suite
de cela que bien sûr les points communs
sont importants et c'est important de
connaître le support de l'hérédité
d'avoir des connaissances en génétiques
de connaître les modes de développement
la biologie cellulaire de ces de tous
ces organismes et d'en tirer des
conclusions notamment pour la santé
humaine mais il est également important
de comprendre que la plupart des
organismes ont des particularités
aujourd'hui si on est victime de la
covid-19 c'est parce qu'on est infecté
par un coronavirus si on est malade du
paludisme c'est parce qu'on était
infecté par un autre organisme qui n'a
rien à voir qui s'appelle un Plasmodium
voilà et ces différences là comptent
énormément tout autant effectivement que
ces organismes ont tous un support de
l'hérédité basé sur l'ADN ou l'ARN et
donc ce constat en fait qui était
presque de la politique scientifique a
été menée dans les années 80 notamment
à l'origine par des Académies des
sciences aux États-Unis et ont amené à
la popularisation du terme biodiversité
qui est une contraction finalement de
diversité biologique autrement dit
diversité du vivant et comme vous le
savez sans doute dans les années 90 il y
a eu une réunion qui a l'occasion du
Sommet de la Terre à Rio de Janeiro qui
a permis en fait de
en fait de concrétiser cette vision
scientifique par une convention la
convention pour la diversité biologique
donc une convention juridique
contraignante qui aujourd'hui signée par
200 pays notamment bien sûr par la
France et cette convention en fait a
exprimer de manière juridique ce que les
scientifiques avaient essayé de mettre
en exergue à savoir que la diversité du
vivant c'est bien sûr la diversité entre
les individus là j'ai figuré quelques
variétés d'une espèce consommée les
aubergines on pourrait avoir ce même
constat diversité pour pour plein
d'organismes tous les individus sont pas
identiques il y a une diversité entre
les espèces également une bien sûr on
peut on le sait tous il y a par exemple
en France 40000 espèces d'insectes sur
notre territoire métropolitain qui ont
des caractéristiques extrêmement
différentes et puis enfin il y a une
diversité dans la manière dont ces
espèces s'organisent entre elles au sein
de ce que l'on appelle des écosystèmes
dans des systèmes d'espèces autrement
dit et donc évidemment une forêt
tropicale une savane une peinture
tempérée ou une pelouse alpine n'ont pas
les mêmes caractéristiques écologiques
donc finalement la diversité du vivant
c'est l'appréhension de cette diversité
à ces trois échelles
le problème en fait c'est que au-delà
ces trois échelles d'études on a aussi
trois dimensions la diversité du vivant
qui sont généralement mal perçues on
perçoit pas ce qui ne nous est pas
possible de percevoir avec nos sens et
notamment la partie microbienne de la
biodiversité ça paraît un peu un truc
mais néanmoins il est important de le
rappeler on a l'impression suite aux
avancées de l'hygiène pasteurienne au
début du 20e siècle finalement les
microbes sont globalement nuisibles et
qu'il importe de sang de s'en
débarrasser en réalité notamment dans
notre propre corps nous avons autant de
bactéries que de cellules de notre
propre corps c'est-à-dire à peu près 30
000 milliards d'individus ces bactéries
au sein de notre propre corps pèsent
environ 3 kg pour une personne adulte en
bonne santé si nous n'avons pas ces
bactéries nous mourrons nous ne sommes
pas capables de survivre ne nous
développer d'avoir un système
immunitaire d'avoir un système
neurologique qui fonctionne correctement
à tel point aujourd'hui qu'un enfant né
par césarienne donc et comme on le dit
souillé sur les voies de la maman de
manière qui puisse acquérir une partie
de cette communauté microbienne donc
bien sûr il y a d'autres microbes qui ne
sont pas désirés dont on se débarrasse
puisqu'ils sont pathogènes mais
néanmoins nous avons besoin de ces
micro-organismes qui ne sont pas
évidemment perceptibles à du fait de nos
sens limités la même constat s'étend à
l'ensemble du vivant à chaque arbre est
lié à des champignons un maître de
racine d'arbre c'est 1000 mètres de
champignons de filaments mycéliens qui
procure de la nourriture un gramme de
sol donc vraiment à peine un dé à coudre
d'un sol y compris celui qu'on pourrait
trouver dans des jardinières ou des
pelouses ici autour du bâtiment
contiennent un milliard de bactéries à
peu près 5000 espèces de bactéries donc
un sol n'est rien s'il n'y a pas ces
bactéries qui qui captent l'azote et
donc cette dimension microbienne on a du
mal à appréhender une deuxième dimension
qui est également souvent qui est qui
est réduite à l'état un peu de d'image
d'Épinal c'est la dimension évolutive de
la biodiversité on sait que tous les
organismes descendent la même ancêtre
commun et aujourd'hui on a une diversité
qui est prodigieuse avec plus de 2
millions d'espèces déjà décrites par la
science à la surface de la planète mais
on a du mal évidemment à se rendre
compte du fait de la lenteur de ce
mécanisme que tous ces organismes sont
issus d'un même ancêtre commun et enfin
dernière élément qui est également très
important ce sont les interactions voilà
j'ai figuré une abeille butinant une
fleur puisque bien sûr c'est
l'interaction qu'aujourd'hui on comprend
la plus facilement c'est d'ailleurs
assez facile à comprendre puisque une
ruche au meilleur de la saison ça
comprend 50000 individus qui passent
plusieurs heures par jour à butiner sur
des fleurs donc évidemment on aurait du
mal à ne pas le percevoir mais il y a
plein d'autres interactions qui sont
vraiment
permanentes au sein des écosystèmes même
au sujet de la pollinisation par exemple
en France métropolitaine nous avons plus
de 5500 pollinisateurs différents qui
sont la plupart du temps des insectes et
comme je le disais auparavant il y a
aucun arbre qui ne dispose pas de ces
partenaires champignons mycorhiziens
donc comme on le voit les interactions
sont également un domaine qui est
finalement un peu evanescent et qu'on a
du mal à appréhender donc à chaque fois
qu'on considère la manière dont la
biodiversité va changer au cours du
temps en fait il faut se rappeler de ces
trois dimensions qui devront être prises
en compte d'une manière ou d'une autre
alors en dépit de ces apparences quand
on parle d'évolution on se réfère on a
l'impression qu'on se réfère à des
phénomènes très anciens qui se passent à
une vitesse très lente mais en dépit de
ses apparences la biodiversité est
extrêmement dynamique puisque là le
constat qu'on vient de faire c'est un
constat un peu de d'État
en stase et une première dimension de
ces dynamique de la biodiversité c'est
que malgré tout elle évolue très vite à
chaque fois qu'il y a un événement de
reproduction de reproduction sexuée on a
donc la fusion de deux génomes et puis
un certain nombre de mutations qui
interviennent de cette manière nous
transmettons nous-mêmes à nos enfants
sans à 150 mutations à chaque génération
mais il y a d'autres événements
évolutifs qui vont encore plus vite et
on en a on en est témoin notamment avec
l'antibio-résistance qui peut apparaître
en quelques années et qui cause
aujourd'hui plusieurs centaines de
milliers de morts dans le monde ou avec
par exemple les chapes l'échappement
vaccinal qui est une évidemment une
problématique importante en ces temps de
pandémie autrement dit si l'on construit
un vaccin qui est particulièrement
efficace à un moment donné si le
micro-organisme évolue tels que c'est le
cas pour le Sark of 2 quelques années
après malheureusement en fait l'immunité
acquise peut être moins compétente par
rapport à
grâce au vaccin peut-être moins
compétent par rapport à ce virus donc en
fait l'évolution peut aller assez vite
en quelques années finalement les
organismes qui vont être confrontés à un
changement d'environnement en
l'occurrence une bactérie c'est son
environnement c'est nos cellules et les
antibiotiques on peut imaginer des
organismes dans le milieu naturel qui
sont soumis aussi à des changements
d'environnement notamment climatique en
quelques années on peut avoir des
changements assez importants au plan
génétique qui peuvent avoir des
conséquences pour le futur et d'autre
part il y a également des aspects
plasticité de reproduction et de et de
dispersion des individus qui sont
importants par exemple j'ai pris deux
faits qui nous sont très familiers qui
montrent à quel point quelques quelques
fois nous avons du mal à faire avec avec
cette plasticité et cette capacité à se
reproduire la capacité à se reproduire
comme Darwin l'a appelé c'est une
capacité qui permet de croissance
géométrique des populations si un
individu est capable d'avoir
4 descendants et chacun de ces cas
descendants lui-même capable d'avoir
quatre descendants ainsi de suite au
bout de quelques années s'il y avait pas
l'imitation à cette reproduction la
surface de la Terre serait couverte par
des individus de chaque espèce donc en
réalité il y a une certaine mortalité
qui intervient et puis à des
antagonistes entre espèces mais grâce à
cela nous avons un certain contrôle la
plupart des populations qui se passent
de manière naturelle malheureusement
dans certains cas suite à nos
interventions on a justement des
contrôles qui sont altérés alors c'est
le cas par exemple pour les populations
de sangliers en France métropolitaine
les tableaux de chasse qui sont
maintenant contrôlés par l'ofb en fait
et autrefois par l'ONCFS en fait font
état 30000 sangliers tués chaque année
en France dans les années 70 et
aujourd'hui de 800 000 sangliers tués
d'autre part on
sait très bien on sait très bien que
d'autres organismes ont également du mal
à comment dire à être contrôlé dans
notre environnement c'est le cas aussi
par exemple d'un certain nombre
d'organismes vecteurs j'ai figuré le
fameux moustique tigre qui aujourd'hui
occupe les trois quarts du territoire
métropolitain qui est notamment vecteur
pour un certain nombre de maladies comme
la dengue qui a fait son apparition à
plusieurs reprises sur le territoire
métropolitain donc là encore on voit que
la dynamique de ces populations n'est
pas et peut-être rapide et difficile à
contrôler et demande à un intérêt
constant pour pour arriver à ce contrôle
alors le souci aussi c'est qu'on se
place dans un dans un système qui est en
perturbation et pas seulement à cause du
changement climatique un système du
vivant qui est perturbé par 5 grandes
causes toutes d'origine humaine telle
que ça a été diagnostiquée par la
plateforme
IPS qui est l'équivalent du GIEC pour la
biodiversité donc une plateforme qui
rassemble environ 150 pays à l'échelle
du monde y compris bien entendu la
France moi je suis moi-même représentant
du CNRS à l'IPES et en fait les cinq
grandes causes qui ont été évaluées
notamment quand l'IPBS s'est réuni à
Paris en 2019 sur des causes que tout le
monde connaît peu ouprou mais dans les
travaux scientifiques ont montré
l'intensité et l'importance en regard du
déclin la biodiversité la première cause
c'est le c'est la conversion des milieux
on entend par là la déforestation la
suppression des zones humides d'une
manière générale la manière dont nous
altérons le paysage et dont nous
diminuons sa diversité évidemment cette
cette altération est considérable
aujourd'hui les trois quarts des zones
humides ont disparu dans le monde chaque
année il disparaît encore 10 millions de
forêt tropicale
10 millions d'hectares pardon de forêts
tropicales et cela va te perdre
également avec des prélèvements qui vont
s'accroissant les prélèvements en
matière de bois dans les forêts de 40%
en 40 ans la plupart un tiers des stocks
de poissons sont en surpêche donc on est
vraiment dans une situation où les
prélèvements ne font que s'accentuer et
ils ne sont pas nécessairement
d'ailleurs en relation
arithmétique avec la taille de la
population humaine bon ce qui serait
assez logique par ailleurs la même
manière les pollutions sont une autre
course de une autre cause de
perturbation de la biodiversité elles
ont elles ont augmenté de manière
considérable on sait aujourd'hui que la
masse de plastique qui est présente à la
surface du globe terrestre est
équivalente à l'ensemble de la biomasse
animale donc on est vraiment dans une
situation où nous avons complètement
changé l'état de la de la planète à un
point qui est difficile d'imaginer puis
par ailleurs dans les systèmes
agro-industriels nous avons nous
produisons une quantité d'intrants nous
introduisons une quantité d'un train
considérable et des intrants qui sont
souvent d'un facteur de toxicité
supérieur
par plusieurs milliers de fois
une des causes de perturbation à la
biodiversité c'est également le
changement climatique puisque c'est le
sujet d'aujourd'hui et il s'agit d'un
réchauffement bien sûr qui est qui est
mesuré de manière globale mais qui se
traduit par des aléas qui sont plus
fréquents de manière locale c'est
souvent à travers ces aléas que nous
percevons ce changement et puis enfin la
dernière cause de perturbation de la
biodiversité ce sont les transports
d'espèces les transports aériens et
maritimes ont augmenté de plus de 1000%
durant les dernières décennies et donc
il est impossible malgré tous les
contrôles sanitaires de ne pas que ces
transports n'occasionnent pas des
transports des espèces à la surface du
globe ils ont augmenté de 70% en 50 ans
et
le fait le bilan économique de ces
transports d'espèces c'est à peu près 5%
du PIB mondial chaque année donc ça
représente quelque chose d'absolument
colossal en termes de tentative de
contrôle de problèmes d'invasion dans
les cultures de problèmes d'invasion
dans les systèmes de santé etc donc on
est confronté à ces cinq causes de je
vais même maintenant me focaliser
brièvement sur le changement climatique
qui est la cause dont nous parlons
aujourd'hui et qui interagit bien sûr
avec les quatre autres causes alors les
effets du changement climatique ils
peuvent se résumer grosso modo en trois
catégories il y a des écosystèmes
entiers qui peuvent disparaître et qui à
l'échelle de quelques de quelques
décennies c'est le cas bien sûr par
exemple des récifs coralliens une un des
effets du changement climatique qui est
largement médiatisé le réchauffement de
l'eau la sidification de l'eau par
dissolution du gaz carbonique provoque
un blanchiment ce qu'on appelle un
blanchiment des coraux puisque ces
coraux expulse les petites algues
symbiotiques qu'il contiennent et
deviennent incapables de survivre donc à
l'échelle à l'échéance de quelques
décennies nous perdons probablement
l'ensemble des récifs coralliens il faut
il faut rappeler que les récifs
coralliens c'est un tiers de la
biodiversité marine mais c'est également
la protection de 100 à 300 millions de
personnes contre les tsunamis et les
vagues et les rates donc si les récifs
coralliens meurent ils sont ils
deviennent des objets inertes qui
finiront par être détruit par le ressac
et permettre malheureusement qu'un
certain nombre d'événements marins
importants portent Thor à 100 300
millions de personnes en zone littorale
un deuxième effet du changement
climatique ce sont les
dysfonctionnements graves qui peuvent
arriver dans les écosystèmes au plan au
plan fonctionnel donc j'ai pris un seul
exemple mais on pourrait multiplier ces
exemples par milliers tout simplement
par exemple on a certains individus
certains organismes qui sont très
sensibles à certains manifestations du
changement climatique comme par exemple
le réchauffement mais aussi le
développement d'épisode 7 sous certains
climats c'est le cas par exemple d'un
certain nombre de pollinisateurs on le
sait aujourd'hui par exemple les
bourdons qui sont les premiers
pollinisateurs il faut le rappeler des
tomates donc plus de bourdons plus de
tomates sont particulièrement affectés
par des épisodes de sécheresse important
dans l'hémisphère nord donc à l'échelle
de quelques décennies là encore on peut
craindre d'avoir un certain nombre de
cultures qui sont affectés directement
dans leur productivité il faut rappeler
que 80% des plantes à fleurs ont besoin
de pollinisateur mais même les plantes
qui sont offertes peuvent avoir une
productivité accrue si elles sont
pollinisées par exemple un champ de
colza auto fertile produit 30 % en plus
s'il est pollinisé donc pas de
pollinisateur il y a non seulement un
problème de cessation de culture pour un
certain nombre d'espèces mais également
un problème de plafonnement de la
production pour bien d'autres enfin
troisième effet du changement climatique
ce sont des effets directs et
dévastateurs directement liés aux aléas
là j'ai pris la photographie des
incendies qui étaient arrivés dans des
forêts tropicales ils n'ont pas dans des
savanes c'était vraiment un feu de forêt
en Nouvelle-Galles du Sud en Australie
il y a quelques années et c'était un
c'était un événement particulièrement
catastrophique mais nous avons vécu
nous-mêmes sur nos territoires
métropolitains ce type d'événements ils
sont amenés naturellement à se
reproduire de plus en plus puisque ces
événements en fait sont liés à des aléas
qui interviennent régulièrement au sein
des systèmes atmosphériques alors là il
y a encore un autre petit souci de
projection donc je vais peut-être
essayer de continuer de manière
voilà de manière
indépendante du de la présentation donc
un des constats de cette de cette
situation c'est que nous sommes
confrontés à un système qui malgré sa
vitesse relativement lente d'évolution
à sa propre dynamique cette dynamique
elle intervient à plusieurs égards ou
pour des années suite aux circonstances
du milieu et notamment
milieu qui est particulièrement
qui est particulièrement comment dire
personnifié par le par le changement
climatique
voyons aussi que la biodiversité ce sont
c'est un ensemble de d'organismes qui
ont leur propre capacité de reproduction
de dispersion d'évolution
et que cette puissance qui l'aurait
conférée par ces mécanismes en fait
peut-être utiliser un autre bénéfice si
nous savons utiliser ces
caractéristiques c'est aujourd'hui ce
que l'on appelle des solutions fondées
sur la nature un concept qui a été
développé par l'ICN qui est aujourd'hui
financée du point de vue de la recherche
par des instances européennes et par le
Ministère de la Recherche les solutions
fondées sur la nature permettent
notamment d'avoir un regard différent
sur le vivant et d'utiliser sa dynamique
à notre bénéfice autrement dit par
exemple si nous voulons
compenser les effets du changement
climatique notamment par exemple avec
les systèmes forestiers nous allons
devoir bien sûr planter des arbres
planter ces arbres ça se fera de manière
cohérente avec la capacité de ces arbres
à vivre dans un climat qui continuera à
évoluer dans un premier temps de manière
négative de planter des arbres qui de
manière cohérente également avec la
nature des sols sur lesquels ils sont
plantés si ces plantations réussissent
nous avons finalement une série de CO
bénéfices qui sont attendus ces copines
c'est bien sûr la captation de carbone
c'est la régulation climatique puisque
ces arbres ont un effet sur la
circulation de l'eau sur la capacité
du climat à se réguler naturellement et
puis la présentation de ces arbres c'est
aussi un réservoir de biodiversité
important néanmoins l'ensemble de ces de
ces conséquences sera d'autant plus
importante que notre
notre exploitation des arbres sera faite
en regard de leur propre dynamique donc
il importe par exemple de planter les
arbres qui que l'on exploite avec un
turnover relativement faible dans
certaines zones de manière à permettre
une meilleure captation du carbone les
arbres vieux en fait contiennent
beaucoup plus carbone que des arbres
jeunes et puis d'autre part la
biodiversité résidant dans des forêts
anciennes et beaucoup plus importante
donc il importe par exemple quand on
utilise des solutions fondées sur la
nature de prendre en compte la dynamique
de la biodiversité de manière que c'est
dynamique puisse se perpétuer
en aboutissant aux résultats que nous
souhaitions obtenir dès le départ tout
en permettant aux activités de la
société qui sont résidentes au sein au
sein des écosystèmes voilà je vous
remercie je pourrai pas aller prendre
plus de temps d'autant plus que les
quelques conclusions que je voulais vous
présenter seront pas être présentés à
l'écran voilà je vous remercie
je pense que vous aurez l'occasion aussi
sur les questions de la salle et
peut-être même des internautes si
certains nous écoutent
je pense qu'après c'est après cette
présentation exhaustive on posera nos
questions plus tard
madame Anne-Christine Monet vous êtes
vous peut-être
plus sur les actions de conservation
vous allez peut-être nous amener une
petite note d'optimisme à savoir la
façon dont on pourrait réintroduire
certaines espèces bien que on sache que
c'est parfois une goutte d'eau mais bon
je pense que vous allez pouvoir
développer ça et nous entendons ensuite
en troisième lieu monsieur Kramer qui
sera en visio
merci Madame la rapporteur mesdames
Messieurs les parlementaires je risque
d'avoir quelques difficultés sans
l'appui de mon diaporama mais
effectivement je je m'attarderai pas
spécifiquement peut-être sur le cas
derrière introduction d'espèces parce
que je voulais remettre justement les
actions de conservation dans un contexte
plus large et celui donc du contexte du
changement climatique
[Musique]
sans diapo il risque de manquer quelques
belles cartes de biodiversité mais je
vais essayer de rebondir et d'ailleurs
je voulais illustrer cette présentation
avec des belles images de la nature et
en fait quand on parle de nature vous
avez sans doute vos propres images qui
vous viennent à l'esprit avec votre
imaginaire associée et en effet la
nature apporte une inspiration
spirituelle essentielle à l'humanité et
pas seulement la nature contribue à la
qualité de vie
en apportant ce qui est essentiel à la
survie de notre humanité ainsi que des
biens matériels
très bien merci
très bien alors ce sont des faits qui
sont maintenant scientifiques en bien
établis on parle des contributions à la
nature de la nature aux personnes donc
vous retrouvez sur ce tableau des
contributions de régulation régulation
du climat justement des événements
extrêmes de la qualité de l'air vous
retrouvez les conditions matérielles à
l'énergie à l'alimentation à la médecine
et des contributions non matériel à
notre inspiration notre bien-être notre
identité
or l'examen de plus de 2000 études
montre un déclin pour 14 de chez 18
contributions de la nature ce sont les
flèches décroissantes sur le tableau et
qui menace actuellement la qualité de
vie des populations donc ce sont pour
l'essentiel des fonctions de régulation
et des contributions non matérielles
tandis que depuis 1970 la production a
augmenté dans les secteurs de
l'agriculture de la pêche des bioénergie
et des industries extractives ce qui
suggère que cette hausse n'est pas
souvent viable à long terme
alors la majeure partie des
contributions
pardon
la majeure partie des conclusions que je
vous présente aujourd'hui proviennent en
fait de ces deux rapports la synthèse de
l'IPBES donc plus de 15000 publications
scientifiques accompagnées d'un
synthétisé et accompagné d'un résumé à
l'intention des décideurs et des
conclusions d'un atelier commun entre
l'IPES et le GIEC sur le lien entre
biodiversité et climat
alors les causes du déclin de la
biodiversité ils sont également bien
documentés le changement d'utilisation
des terres et des mers l'exploitation
directe par la chasse la pêche
l'exploitation forestière en troisième
position apparaît le changement
climatique qui nous intéresse
aujourd'hui la pollution les espèces
exotiques envahissantes donc ça ce sont
les facteurs directs mais qui résultent
d'un ensemble de causes sociétales
profondes qui peuvent être
démographiques la dynamique des
populations humaines socioculturelle les
modes de consommation économiques
technologiques ce sont les facteurs
indirects
alors parmi ces facteurs à quel point
l'impact du changement climatique dont
on parle aujourd'hui est important comme
vous le voyez les changements
climatiques sont un facteur de
changement direct mais qui va exercer
des façons croissante l'impact d'autres
facteurs sur la nature et le bien-être
humain des auteurs ont estimé que
l'impact du changement climatique
devrait dépasser les autres menaces au
cours du 21e siècle tant par ces effets
directs que par l'intensification des
interactions avec les autres facteurs
alors concrètement comment le changement
climatique impact la biodiversité alors
d'abord tous les compartiments de la
biosphère sont impactés la terre la mer
l'eau douce les impacts ont été
documentés à tous les niveaux
d'organisation du vivant c'est ce que
donc parler monsieur grandcola
précédemment depuis les gènes les
individus jusqu'au des écosystèmes dû à
des changements entre les interactions
entre espèces et les changements de
composition des communautés animales
végétales fongiques
de génération d'individus en génération
d'individus les espèces doivent
s'adapter aux nouvelles conditions pour
persister sinon s'éteindre localement ou
globalement
et parmi les nombreuses réponses
adaptives adaptatives possibles il y a
celle de se déplacer pour suivre son
optimum climatique
alors ici vous reconnaîtrez sur ces
cartes les
îles au sud-est de l'Asie et puis le sud
de l'Afrique les zones vertes c'est ce
qu'on appelle les zones clés pour la
biodiversité et c'est un instrument de
conservation qui définit des sites
d'importance pour la persistance
mondiale de la biodiversité et toutes
les petites flèches noires en fait ce
sont la vitesse et la direction des
changements climatiques pour ces zones
c'est-à-dire la distance à parcourir
pour rester en phase avec ses conditions
climatiques optimum et plus le
réchauffement est important plus cette
distance climatique augmente
un autre élément apparaît que vous
verrez peut-être mieux ce sont les
flèches rouges elles indiquent les zones
clés de biodiversité qui vont perdre
totalement leurs climat et vous voyez
que c'est principalement sur les îles et
en zone côtière en effet de par leur
isolement les écosystèmes insillaires
sont particulièrement menacés ainsi on
estime que sur le continent
la plupart des zones clés de
biodiversité donc ces zones de
conservation vont subir des changements
subir des changements de leurs
conditions climatiques à un de ou 6
degrés de réchauffement acides c'est en
revanche près de 40% des zones clés de
biodiversité sur les îles qui perdent
leurs climat
or il incombe à la France une grande
responsabilité dans la préservation de
ces écosystèmes insulaires puisqu'en
effet avec seulement 0,08% de la surface
sur Terre les collectivités françaises
d'outre-mer abritent plus de 3000
espèces de plantes et 380 espèces de
vertébrés qui sont strictement
endémiques c'est-à-dire qu'on ne trouve
qu'en France c'est plus que dans toute
l'Europe continentale et la perte de ces
espèces représenterait la perte d'un
patrimoine commun et culturel
inestimable
alors je vous ai parlé ici
d'écosystème exceptionnel de par leur
richesse ou leur histoire récemment des
chercheurs se sont demandés quel était
le risque climatique des arbres et des
arbustes qui sont présents dans les
villes du monde entier donc on est bien
loin là des forêts d'outre-mer on y
trouve moi majorité des espèces qui ont
été plantés
ils ont montré que plus de la moitié des
espèces dépasse actuellement les
conditions de température observées dans
l'horaire de répartition géographique
d'ici 2050 sous un scénario à plus 6
degrés 76% des espèces d'arbres dans nos
villes sont à risque climatique dans le
futur et pour ainsi représenter une
diminution des contributions de cette
nature ordinaire tels que la dissipation
de la chaleur urbaine par évaporation
aussi bien qu'une contribution au
bien-être et à la santé mentale des
populations urbaines
alors quels sont les implications de ce
changement climatique pour la
conservation de la biodiversité
globalement on a des méthodes efficaces
pour conserver la biodiversité les aires
protégées la restauration des habitats
les plans d'action de protection ou
réintroduction d'espèces qui étaient au
bord de l'extinction ces actions ont
mené à de nombreux succès une
biodiversité bien plus importante aurait
été perdue sans les efforts déployer
jusqu'à présent
mais comme tout le reste la conservation
de la biodiversité doit aussi se
réinventer dans ce contexte
d'environnement changeant et donc si on
le prend le cas des exemples des aires
protégés avec des zones de nature intact
qui sont très fragmentées et au sein
d'une mosaïque de paysages très modifiée
l'importance de la connectivité des
corridors de migration c'est accru pour
pouvoir maintenir des populations
d'espèces des habitats des fonctions
écologiques ainsi que le besoin
d'intégrer des zones protégées dans un
contexte spatial plus large et plus
inclusif socialement
cependant ces actions de conservation
seul ne suffiront pas à enrayer le
déclin de la biodiversité pourquoi parce
qu'elles ne font pas le foie pas le
poids face aux pressions face au niveau
de pression mis sur les écosystèmes
aussi la résolution de la crise
climatique seule ne résoudra pas la
crise de la biodiversité et à contrario
la synthèse d'études alerte également
sur les effets néfastes à la
biodiversité deux heures certaines
actions de lutte pour le climat c'est le
cas par exemple des actions qui entre en
compétition pour l'espace avec la
biodiversité comme les monocultures
d'arbres ou pour la bioénergie
les experts senial également un besoin
urgent de mieux évaluer et prendre en
compte les impacts sur la biodiversité
de certaines mesures technologiques
d'atténuation du climat
mais cependant et là je vais être
positive il reste des solutions dans
l'ensemble il existe plus de communices
que de compromis antagonistes entre
antagonistes entre les actions de
conservation et les objectifs
d'atténuation du climat c'est ce qu'on
trouve dans la synthèse de ces travaux
alors la première action pour conserver
la biodiversité ça va être de lever ces
pressions sur les écosystèmes et
notamment les pressions non climatiques
dès qu'on lève des sécrétions des
améliorations rapides sont souvent
observées alors cela nécessite d'agir à
la fois sur
les les causes directes du déclin dont
on a parlé le changement d'usage des
terres la pollution l'exploitation des
espèces et les causes indirectes que
sont nos valeurs les styles de vie et de
consommation l'organisation
socio-écosystémique de nos sociétés
jusque là des changements les
changements en ce sens n'ont pas été
assez rapide et un pli des changements
transformateurs à engager maintenant
c'est à dire une réorganisation
fondamentale systémique des facteurs
économiques sociaux technologiques y
compris les paradigmes et les
sparaddings les objectifs et les valeurs
il s'agit par exemple
d'une réduction de la consommation et
des déchets de l'évolution des régimes
alimentaires d'une exploitation durable
des biens et des services et notamment
dans l'alimentation et c'est ces
changements en profondeur qui peut
permettre de faire la différence pour un
fléchir comme vous voyez ici la courbe
du déclin de la biodiversité et créer de
voix des voies de développement
résilientes au climat et à la
biodiversité
voilà je vous remercie de votre
attention
merci beaucoup pour cette exposée à la
fois
vertigineux mais passionnant
pour lequel on aura sûrement des
questions même très très concrètes
finalement pour ma part
monsieur wolfrang-cramer nous a rejoint
oui vous êtes à distance monsieur Kramer
vous nous entendez
donc vous êtes directeur de recherche à
l'Institut méditerranéen biodiversité
d'écologie marine et continentale
d'Aix-en-Provence et
vous allez nous parler de votre
expérience de membres du GIEC pour
évoquer le réchauffement comme menace
sur la biodiversité
nous écoutons monsieur Kramer
merci beaucoup pour l'invitation
j'espère que je puisse partager où il
m'en écran une seconde
prendre le bon là
vous voyez mon mon diapo très bien
ok merci merci donc quelques mots sur le
réchauffement et les prospectives
surtout je vais le faire trois points
vite fait par le 6e rapport de GIEC
publié cette année on attend pour la
dernière partie quoi de neuf que parce
qu'on a parlé de de
la crise de la vivacité du climat depuis
des années je me mentionner trois enjeux
spécifiques et faire un tout petit
perspective à la fin
le premier point c'est que le GIEC avec
16 nouveaux rapports pour la première
fois vraiment à
insister sur la relation entre la
société humaine les écosystèmes les
changements climatiques comme un
triangle comme comme trois entités qui
sont grande force relation entre entre
eux c'est pas seulement le climat qui
est qui change et qui impacte la société
ou les écosystèmes c'est aussi les
changements des écosystèmes qui changent
qui impacte
c'était et le climat et donc la question
est Christine monnaie l'argent évoqué
c'est comment rentrer en transition
comment comment changer la trajectoire
sur lesquels nous sommes et il y a un
mot clé au milieu de ce diapo c'est
l'urgence à la à l'action on a constaté
d'urgence depuis des années mais quel
est le nom quels sont nos moyens
d'action et une chose que le siècle
fournit beaucoup plus
d'une façon beaucoup plus forte que les
dans les rapports intérieurs c'est des
informations spécifiques très
régionalisées et c'est vraiment je peux
vous donner ça juste comme un guide de
lecture si jamais pour une région
quelconque bien sûr la France
aussi n'importe quel autre région au
monde si on cherche des informations sur
les risques associés avec le changement
climatique pour la biodiversité il faut
aller dans le dans les profondeurs de
rapport dans chapitre on va trouver une
richesse d'informations qui
ou aujourd'hui dans les quelques minutes
que nous avons je voulais juste vous
dire que elle est extrêmement riche et
évidemment pas la même dans toutes les
zones du monde parce que les
informations ne sont pas les mêmes mais
quand même une richesse qui n'existait
pas dans les rapports intérieurs et
c'est
organise aussi dans les tableaux comme
celui-ci vous voyez que que des
informations sur la changement observé
dans les écosystèmes du au changement
climatique et de la structure des
écosystèmes dans la distribution des
espèces dans la phénologie ça veut dire
le développement des espèces dans le
cycle de manière
très très élaborée pour les différentes
régions au monde et les points bleus
dans cette danse tableau sont tous des
pointeurs vers des informations très
spécifiques dans les chapitres néanmoins
global la prospective vous permet à
faire quelques constats et je vous dirai
un de rien de étonnant après les deux
premières interventions il est clair que
le niveau de la température
relative au pré industriel
elle détermine comme bien de la
biodiversité
large nous risquons à perdre et c'est
quantités ne sont pas du tout les mêmes
partout dans le monde déjà parce qu'il
est en température et les impacts
sécheresse pas les mêmes partout et
aussi parce que la biodiversité dans
certaines régions sont plus fragiles que
dans d'autres et c'est là ce reproduise
aussi en mer ou ici c'est là c'est la
biomasse à la biodiversité mais la
biomasse des poissons marins qui qui est
impacté d'une façon très très importante
par les différentes scénarios de
changement climatique la carte o c'est
le changement relativement modeste
en cohérence avec le coeur de Paris par
contre de la carte en bas ça c'est
plutôt le trajectoire qui trajectoire
sur lequel nous sommes actuellement et
nous voyons des zones rouges qui indique
une forte baisse de la productivité mais
aussi des zones vertes où il y a une
augmentation et ce genre de changement
de 20 30% de changement de biomasse
souvent ça implique une perte de la
biodiversité même si c'est même si ça
augmente parce que la structure de
l'écosystème marin est fortement
perturbé
trois points spécifiques que je voudrais
souligner comme conclusion de sixième
rapport la première c'est le risque de
perte de biome comme nous les appelons
les grandes écosystèmes entiers
sur le risque de la perte des récits
coralliens dans les tropiques et les
graves conséquences que que cela pour le
pour l'écosystème pour la biodiversité
mais aussi pour les populations
c'est connu déjà depuis un moment et ça
fait partie des grandes
sujets associés avec le changement
climatique ou en se demande pourquoi la
réaction publique en général n'est pas
plus fort que que c'est le cas c'est
parfois j'ai l'impression que c'est
considéré comme quelque chose qui est
très loin de nous qui ne touchent pas du
tout mais il y en a d'autres d'autres
situations de la même catégorie et une
est associée avec la perte des banques
de la aussi un sujet qui semble être
loin de chez nous mais qui en réalité
est lié avec le reste de l'écosystème
planétaire d'une façon très importante
dès que je perde la banquise je change
complètement la structure de
l'écosystème marin et aussi faut-il dans
le Grand Nord et il y a des impacts par
exemple sur les oiseaux et sur la
productivité de la végétation
au bord de la mer parce qu'il y a plus
le transport des nutriments de la mère
que c'était le cas avant il y a des
nombreuses interactions entre une simple
constat de la perte de la banquise et et
la biodiversité dans toute une zone
beaucoup plus large que cette femme et
le troisième c'est aussi la glace je
m'excuse je sais pas que je suis là
comme glaciologue mais les
processus que nous observons en
Antarctique actuellement et
qui implique une perte de glace beaucoup
plus accéléré que on a pensé encore
quelques années ben ils ont une
conséquence partout dans le monde et
c'est que la hausse de la mer et
beaucoup plus important sera beaucoup
plus important que on y pense
actuellement
que la pensée récemment ça veut dire un
mètre vers la fin du siècle peut-être 2
et avec un look in beaucoup plus
importante dans les années qui viennent
et cela met en cause j'ai pas d'image
des belles coach pour vous parce que
vous les connaissez tous mais ça c'est
un impact
a comme conséquence le risque de la
perte totale de littoral tel que nous le
connaissons actuellement dans les années
qui viennent dans les décennies qui
viennent donc à la fois les zones
humides côtières mais aussi des zones
invités des zones agricoles dans les
grandes dettes
deuxième point
très vite en Christine a déjà fait
référence aux solutions basées sur la
nature c'est un sujet très important
pour le GIEC parce qu'on a finalement
reconnu que que effectivement à renforce
l'adaptation et aussi cela des missions
de gaz à effet de serre il est possible
de s'appuyer sur le sur les
sur les écosystèmes et sur la capacité
d'absorber le carbone stocker plus du
carbone et
de rendre plus résiliente la production
de de système agricole et c'est en fait
déjà utilisé c'est ça qui faut prendre
que dans un grand parti de notre
adaptation au changement climatique on
comptabilise déjà l'utilisation de la
biodiversité autre donc à l'envers ce
que si on va vers une grande perte de la
biodiversité telle que les projects
projetés actuellement par le GIEC et par
l'IDP on va aussi perdre notre
résilience
par rapport à ces dites solutions basées
sur la nature pour une meilleure
adaptation et c'est très problème très
très sérieux et finalement un sujet qui
nous a préoccupé assez beaucoup dans la
probation du dernier rapport du GIEC
c'est les conséquences de température
j'ai pas trouvé une belle traduction
pour le mot mais pour vous expliquer
par rapport à votre température mondiale
on regarde actuellement des de la
situation avec un certain optimisme dans
ce sens-là ça veut dire on est dans le
dans un réchauffement très important
on est certainement encore un bon moment
sur cette trajectoire mais on imagine
avec beaucoup d'optimisme et que la
cop27 et les conférences suivantes vont
nous amener vers une accumulation qui va
équilibrer les températures idéalement
tels que c'était
de la signature de l'accord de Paris où
il baisse encore en dessous de ce seuil
de 1,5 et du côté de la biodiversité on
s'est posé la question qu'est-ce que ça
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire est-ce que
c'est le cas
que on peut considérer que quand
dépassement du température et un retour
à l'exemple plus plus sympa après ça va
nous ramener dans un monde aussi plus
riche et plus plus fonctionnel du côté
de la bière du Basset effectivement pas
du tout les cas parce qu'il y a un très
très grand nombre des écosystèmes je les
a déjà évoqué qui qui vont être perdus
et bien leur université va être perdue
au moment que on dépasse les
températures critiques pour ces
écosystèmes et le simple baisse c'est en
peinture vers
quelque chose qui est en dessous un peu
mieux cinq ça va pas permettre de les
récupérer parce que des espèces sont
perdus et souvent en plus comme nous le
observons ici dans le Grand Nord il y a
beaucoup de carbone qui a été perdu à ce
moment-là par ces écosystèmes dégradés
et la conséquence bien sûr ça va être
que c'est beaucoup plus difficile quand
on y pense aujourd'hui de
retourner à des températures en dessous
du un peu plus sec comme c'était prévu
au moment de Paris donc la biodiversité
malheureusement elle elle va rendre plus
difficile les scénarios
très très optimistes que on entend
actuellement que le dépassement va être
que temporaire et que après le
dépassement peut-être rentrera dans une
situation plus simple dernier mot merci
la Christine a déjà fait référence il y
a un rapprochement très très important
entre
les TBS et la vis ici qui qui
est très souhaité par plusieurs raisons
c'est pas que il faut expliquer au
qu'est-ce que c'est la biodiversité là
il y a déjà beaucoup de beaucoup de
compétences mais ce qui est l'ITBS amène
pour pour cela je crois ce qui doit être
c'est le politique en France aussi c'est
que la partie sociale la partie comment
l'homme comme la société humaine dépend
de la biodiversité est prise en compte
d'une façon beaucoup plus efficace
beaucoup plus avec beaucoup plus de
compétences dans les rencontres l'ibbs
et c'est pour ça que je suis très
content de voir ce rapprochement entre
les deux instances de l'interface
science politique
donc merci pour votre attention
merci beaucoup
je
vais avant de donner la parole à mes
collègues à la suite de ces de ces
exposés
passionnantes mais quand même assez
inquiétant
moi je vais avoir une question très
simple je suis sénatrice de la Gironde
on a vu les incendies dévastateurs
on voit que suite à ces incendies là la
végétation reprend à toute vitesse et on
a toujours ce cette comment dire
l'impression que la nature va surmonter
l'événement mais néanmoins
lorsqu'on parle de reforestation on va
peut-être rester sur des schémas un peu
anciens enfin moi ce que moi la question
elle est toute simple comment on fait
pour vulgariser ce que vous nous
présentez là aujourd'hui parce que il y
a un monde entre ce qu'on fait nous à
l'OPEX et ce que on peut diffuser sur
nos nos concitoyens qui sont plus
préoccupés par leur pouvoir d'achat
comment payer l'énergie etc et alors que
le la préoccupation elle devrait être
vraiment celle de celle de chaque quand
je vais pas rentrer dans les détails
j'ai bien aimé l'allusion au nouveau-né
par césarienne qui qui n'a pas le
microbiote parce que je suis même
pédiatre et donc c'est c'est le début de
la vie
effectivement on connaît ce
phénomène
déterminant c'est à dire que le
phénomène qui n'est pas naturel il a
tout de suite un retentissement moi je
vais pas être plus longue je ne sais pas
si monsieur le Président Monsieur
Longuet vous avez des questions et
ensuite je passerai la parole à mes
collègues
moi j'ai un immense respect pour celles
et ceux qui consacrent leur vie à la
science parce qu'ils ont
un effort permanent
qui en effet Florence peut les éloigner
du grand public
parce que le grand public a des
préoccupations qui sont
plus immédiates tu les as évoquées et
c'est d'ailleurs
en fait c'est la dimension philosophique
qui me paraît la plus importante dans
votre
dans votre dans votre présentation ce
matin parce que sur le plan technique je
crois qu'il y a on aimerait vous poser
des milliers de questions et en
particulier
celle vous l'avez évoqué en introduction
il y a une vitalité de la biodiversité
mais cette vitalité au fond en
connaissons nous l'historique
je me souviens que nous avions ici à
l'Office Parlementaire travailler
c'était Jérôme Bignon qui avait
travaillé sur ce sujet sur comment on
pourrait dire des ruptures de système
avec il y avait un mot c'est pas
l'effondrement c'était pas la
disparition qui était pardon
l'extinction voilà exactement donc ce
qui serait intéressant
c'est de bien comprendre
parce que pour l'instant il y a un
coupable c'est l'homme on a bien compris
mais est-ce que la biodiversité
n'obéit pas à des équilibres et des
déséquilibres qui lui soit propre et et
cette question de l'extinction est
intéressante parce que
c'est en fait une question de
nous nous sommes dans une assemblée
politique et nous sommes forcément
tributaires dans nos décisions nos
réflexions nos approches de
l'horizontale qui est celui
des électeurs et des élus c'est aussi un
écosystème les électeurs
ils ont des préoccupations les élus on
les leur s'il existe un office
parlementaire d'évaluation des choses
scientifiques et technologiques c'est
parce qu'on s'est dit tiens ce serait
quand même pas mal de consacrer un peu
de temps à des choses qui ne sont pas
immédiatement politique
mais qui vont définir le cadre dans
lequel nous risquons de vivre
mais les problèmes que vous posez dans
leur articulation avec la politique
sont liés d'abord à ce problème
d'espace-temps et ça m'intéresserait de
connaître avez-vous une historique de la
biodiversité voilà c'est ça la question
la plus concrète que je pourrais poser à
cet instant en vous expliquant que dans
mon esprit
les difficultés auxquelles on va être
confrontés
c'est
la liberté individuelle et collective
et notamment on voit bien
[Musique]
que sautant l'idée d'une responsabilité
humaine et donc en réponse d'une
régulation
mais cette régulation était terrifiante
parce que elle suppose de tout connaître
des tout savoir pour pouvoir tout
imposer avec la certitude d'un résultat
c'est pas un exercice complètement
facile
d'autant plus que
les
d'une réussite pour l'instant de
coopération mondiale
mais il y a un sujet qui est qui est
posé
c'est l'héritage de la consommation
et il y a un autre sujet qui est posé et
qui est éminemment politique
un autre sujet qui est posé c'est celui
de la démographie et de la liberté
démographique
parce que
le bon sens immédiat de nos compatriotes
c'est de se dire oui mais
parce qu'on s'achemine vers les 10
milliards c'est d'habitants que c'est un
peu plus compliqué qu'avant
ce à quoi ce qui contribue à atteindre
ces 10 milliards nous répondons vous
vous avez accumulé beaucoup de choses
avant et donc il y a une facture que
vous devez prendre en charge
et donc on bute immédiatement sur un
problème
de politique internationale qui pour
l'instant n'est pas
formalisé d'une façon conflictuelle mais
qui inévitablement le sera parce que
c'est un vrai débat
et c'est la raison pour laquelle ce qui
m'intéresse ce serait à cet instant
d'avoir une idée de
quand vous avez parlé de la biodiversité
c'est pas un équilibre idéal c'est un
mouvement permanent et
quels ont été les est-ce que l'on a une
idée des mouvements permanents par le
passé
et
l'intelligence humaine a produit
notamment la science-fiction
il y a eu un merveilleux film enfin
merveilleux effrayant qui était green
Solène je crois dans les années
1975-1980 qui avait vulgarisé l'idée
d'une planète totalement saturée où la
vie devenait essentiellement
artificielle parce que la vie naturelle
ne pouvait plus exister
moi j'aimerais
que vous me parliez de cette historique
de la biodiversité
si je peux me permettre merci en fait
effectivement on a un historique de la
biodiversité qui nous est donné par les
sciences de la Terre et notamment par la
paléontologie qui est étudient les
systèmes anciens avec les traces
fossiles ou la géochimie alors cette
historique nous permet de voir que la
biodiversité n'est pas toujours dans un
équilibre stable au cours des temps
notamment du fait des perturbations des
systèmes par des événements cosmiques un
chutes d'astéroïdes ou du fait de
d'épisode volcaniques extraordinairement
intense qui ont amené par exemple à des
expansions de lave sur des territoires
équivalents aujourd'hui à des pays
entiers donc au cours de des temps il y
a effectivement eu des crises
d'extinction c'est d'ailleurs pour ça
qu'on dit qu'on est toujours dit dans la
sixième grande crise d'extinction parce
qu'il y en a eu déjà d'autres en fait
c'était simplement les épisodes les plus
exceptionnels un de ces variations
d'équilibre alors effectivement ces
épisodes ont été exceptionnels néanmoins
ils se déroulait sur des millions
d'années et
véritablement l'espèce humaine n'était
pas présente et donc nous n'avons pas
été victimes le problème de voilà de
l'épisode actuel c'est que nous y sommes
actuellement on a un ordre de grandeur
qui est en termes d'extinction qui est
de l'ordre de 1000 fois plus important
que le taux résiduel habituel sans
intervention humaine et par ailleurs on
est dans un ordre de grandeur qui est de
des milliers de fois plus importants en
termes de taux que
dans les extinctions précédentes en
termes de rapidité donc nous sommes des
milliers de fois plus rapides que les
extinctions historiques par exemple de
l'ordre d'ovicien de la fin du Crétacé
etc et nous sommes mille fois plus
rapides que le taux avant l'arrivée de
l'humanité par exemple laolocène donc
nous sommes dans une situation en fait
de rapidité extrême et effectivement
c'est une situation qui peut-être
anxiogène quand on la considère voilà en
regard de l'existence des sociétés
humaines et leur capacité à se journée
alors moi j'étais moi-même je suis
moi-même j'ai été moi-même par exemple
dans les jours qui viennent de s'écouler
en train de présenter ce type de
situation à des collégiens les lycées
par exemple 200 collégiens lycéens à
Provins hier j'étais avec les chefs de
rédaction de France Télévisions qui
avaient qui ont actuellement des séances
de formation sur ces problématiques donc
on perçoit quand on parle de ces
situations alors caractère anxiogène
puis la difficulté de les expliquer
puisque à chaque fois on parle de
système complexe donc de mon point de
vue il y a un certain nombre de
fondamentaux à présenter de manière que
chacun puisse s'approprier
le constat et les causes et puis après
il y a un certain nombre de solutions et
de solutions heureuses à expliquer de
manière que voilà par exemple par
rapport à la reforestation que l'on
montre qui a des possibilités que ces
possibilités doivent s'appuyer certains
un certain nombre de connaissances de
manière que cette reforestation soit
durable qu'elle puisse dans un étant se
faire malgré le changement climatique
qu'elle puisse aussi contribuer à la
régulation climatique au final tout en
permettant la continuation d'un certain
nombre d'activités humaines et
effectivement c'est un message qui peut
être parfois difficile à délivrer
puisque on doit faire avec cette analyse
historique avec un évaluation des
processus et des causes et puis en même
temps avec un message de solution et de
solutions heureuses mais en même temps
préservant malgré tout la nécessité
d'agir dans l'urgence voilà c'est donc
effectivement une sorte d'enjeu et de
difficultés actuelles dans cette dans
cette crise de l'environnement
je pense avec
Pierre-Henry que nous allons passer la
parole à nos collègues qui nous ont fait
l'amitié de d'être là ce matin parce que
beaucoup ce que je voulais dire c'est
que beaucoup de sénateurs s'excusent
pour les raisons de transport certains
sont rentrés précipitamment hier chez
eux et d'autres qui sont en
Île-de-France ne pouvaient pas nous
rejoindre
ce matin physiquement je remercie à mes
collègues présents
Stéphane piénoir
oui merci chers collègues ce président
mais names et messieurs à une question
un petit peu de néophyte je suis
scientifique mais du côté du mauvais
côté des choses mathématicien très
cartésien je veux une question sur
les deux aspects en fait de sujets qui
nous occupe aujourd'hui à biodiversité
on a beaucoup parlé du de bio du vivant
de la disparition d'une partie du vivant
par le réchauffement par l'impact du
réchauffement climatique et assez peu de
la diversité en fait et ma question est
celle là on observe par le réchauffement
des eaux des mers le remplacement de
certaines populations marines par
d'autres donc une disparaît l'autre
réapparaît c'est vrai aussi pour les
insectes c'est vrai pour je prendrai
l'exemple du frelon asiatique qui
décime les populations d'abeilles
classiques européennes on va dire est-ce
que
évidemment ça marche pas par exemple
pour le récif qui disparaît et qui n'est
pas remplacé par autre chose
d'équivalent mais ma question c'est
finalement en remplaçant une une espèce
vivante par une autre espèce vivante qui
n'était pas
prévu à cet endroit là est-ce que c'est
si grave que ça je le pose
volontairement de manière provocatrice
comme ça
quels sont plus exactement quels sont
les dangers de ce remplacement d'une
population par une espèce par une autre
Philippe Bolot puis Angèle Préville
posez leurs questions et comme ça vous
répartirez les réponses merci même le
rapporteur merci beaucoup mesdames
mesdames et messieurs pour votre
présentation qui était très éclairante
et qui qui montre l'importance de cet
enjeu de la biodiversité la question va
être très simple vous avez évoqué de la
disparition des espèces donc des
effectifs qui se réduisent n'y a-t-il
pas aussi des évolutions d'effectifs qui
augmentent et je pense en particulier
aux maladies et aux maladies qui
pouvaient être limitées à certaines
zones géographiques qui vont se
développer découvert de nouvelles zones
qu'en est-il de cet équilibre de ces
espèces qui sont plutôt des
micro-organismes qui pourraient
augmenter et affecter les des continents
ou des parties de la terre où elles
n'étaient pas présentes
oui merci Madame la rapporteur donc
merci à vous tous et tous pour vos
présentations très éclairantes et on a
l'impression qu'on apprend toujours on
apprend toujours plus sur ces sujets là
moi j'étais très intéressée par la
partie microbienne parce que c'est vrai
que c'est quelque chose dont on parle
peu même si
microbiote humain a été mis en valeur
ces dernières années donc je pense que
c'est quelque chose peut-être il
faudrait voilà diffuser davantage parce
que je enfin pour moi elle a ses
phénomènes complexes sont à la portée de
toutes et tous si on sait bien les
expliquer et j'avais une question sur
qui rejoint celle de mes collègues et ce
que je pose un petit peu différemment
est-ce que dans les évolutions que nous
sommes en train de vivre sur la
disparition d'espèces et notamment des
pollinisateurs est-ce que la façon dont
nous avons nous de nous nourrir est-ce
que ce sera encore possible demain voilà
qui d'entre vous se lance pour les
réponses
de reparler à nouveau alors
effectivement là on peut se poser la
question de est-ce que est-ce que
finalement la biodiversité n'est pas
dans un équilibre qui pourrait
finalement arriver à une composition des
écosystèmes dans lesquels des espèces se
substituent à d'autres et puis on se
retrouve au final avec des écosystèmes
toujours fonctionnels même si on a pu
les espèces habituelles alors le souci
en fait c'est déjà qu'il y a dans cette
crise d'extinction
une crise d'extinction ça suppose que le
taux de d'extinction et devient
infiniment plus important que le taux de
spécial sur d'apparition des espèces
c'est en fait le diagnostic d'une crise
si d'habits dans une situation
d'équilibre on va dire on a la richesse
des écosystèmes même s'il varie dans le
temps et dans l'espace qui reste à peu
près constante aujourd'hui dans une
situation où il y a pas seulement
substitution à certaines espèces par
d'autres mais il y a disparition d'une
très grande quantité d'espèces et donc
il y a pas forcément substitution
ensuite il y a le problème qui a été
évoqué par mes collègues notamment par
Anne-Christine Monet des services rendus
par cette biodiversité donc on a on a
l'habitude de considérer qu'ils sont
immenses et que finalement de la même
manière que voilà il y a de la pluie du
soleil il y a également de la
pollinisation ou la fertilité des sols
on s'aper on s'aperçoit malheureusement
qu'avec la disparition d'un certain
nombre d'espèces à l'horizon 2050 on est
à peu près sur une prévision d'un
million d'espèces qui auront disparu
c'est à dire la moitié des espèces
connues sur terre et à peu près 10% de
ce qui est vraisemblablement présent sur
la planète malheureusement ces
extinctions en masse amènent une
certaine nombre de pertes de services
alors parmi ces services je peux
répondre aux deux autres questions au
moins de manière préliminaire parmi ces
services il y a le service de finalement
de maintien de la santé humaine
maintiennent la santé humaine c'est tout
simplement parce que les pathogènes en
fait sont quelquefois transmis
directement quand on fréquente certains
réservoirs ou transmis via certains
vecteurs comme les moustiques ou
l'éthique malheureusement avec la
disparition de certaines espèces par
exemple des spectateurs certains
réservoirs deviennent plus importants
avec la fragmentation des forêts la
promiscuité entre les humains et les
réservoirs devient également plus
fréquentes et donc on se retrouve dans
des situations déséquilibres ou
effectivement le nombre de maladies
augmente depuis 1950 il y a à peu près
300 pics d'émergence de pic épidémie ou
de maladies émergentes qui se sont
déroulées donc on est dans une situation
inquiétante de ce point de vue là
effectivement il y a également le
phénomène de dégel des permafrost qui
amènent à ce que certains
microorganismes anciens sont en contact
avec les populations humaines il y a des
cas de charbon par exemple qui sont
apparus à peu près au cercle polaire
dans les populations humaines qui ont
été en contact avec des charbons qui se
sont enfin avec des bactéries pardon qui
se sont réveillés si je puis dire après
le rêver le dégel les permafrost donc on
a effectivement aussi un service en
matière de santé qui est en train de se
dégrader et on en était moins
aujourd'hui avec la glycémie quel que
soit son origine elle provient bien
effectivement de micro-organismes qui à
l'origine ont été étudiés dans des
espèces réservoirs
d'autres services bien sûr c'est la
fourniture de nourriture et là on se
trouve dans une situation qu'il faut
arriver à resituer dans sa dynamique
dans les années 50 on a eu une
mécanisation de l'agriculture et puis un
changement génétique dans un certain
nombre de productions par exemple le blé
avec l'introduction du gène de nanisme
qui a permis à une production
alimentaire industrielle de devenir
extrêmement importante alors en
parallèle la population humaine a cru
même si elle est censée se stabiliser
naturellement autour de 10 milliards
d'individus aujourd'hui les deux tiers
de cette population humaine sont
tributaires de cette production
industrielle agricole le souci
aujourd'hui c'est que cette production
industrielle agricole a des externalités
négatives en grand nombre qui mettent en
danger ça son propre devenir et donc on
se trouve dans une situation où
aujourd'hui où cette production plafonne
commence à du fait que 40% des sols
arabes sont dégradés du fait qu'un
certain nombre de pollinisateurs sont en
train de disparaître comment ça faire
défaut dans un certain nombre
d'écosystèmes agricoles qui s'agisse de
la Chine de l'Europe ou d'Amérique du
Nord par exemple donc on est
effectivement dans une situation où se
plafonnement la production alimentaire
est inquiétant inquiétant d'autant plus
que actuellement il y a plus d'un
milliard d'êtres humains qui ne
dépendent pas de cette production
alimentaire industrielle qui dépendent
encore d'espèces sauvages comme la
souligner l'ipébèse en juillet à bonne
année et cette partie de l'humanité
suite à l'exode rural dans les pays du
Sud suite à la destruction des milieux
naturels risque en plus de venir frapper
à la porte de cette production agricole
industrielle alimentaire donc on est
dans une situation aujourd'hui où la
production plafonne ou le nombre
d'humains qui en dépend ne va augmenter
et où des services rendus par la
biodiversité continue à décliner donc
d'où l'importance d'un fléchir dès
aujourd'hui cette trajectoire
l'expression monsieur grand-cola parce
que notre troisième intervenant vous
écoute attentivement mais ne souhaite
pas réintervenir donc vous avez la
parole peut-être pour reprendre la
première question un peu sur sur cette
sur ces notions de remplacement c'est
sûr que du fait de cette grande
diversité on a en effet des espèces qui
peut être redondantes retenant pour les
services mais on estime aussi qu'on peut
perdre une part de la de la diversité
qui va qui est irremplaçable et c'est
aussi une
du fait de ces
longues histoires évolutive de certaines
branches qui pourraient disparaître à
jamais et on considère que ce sont
potentiellement des pertes d'options
pour pour les écosystèmes mais aussi
pour nos sociétés c'est-à-dire que on ne
sait pas ce qu'on peut perdre pour pour
le futur
justement c'est ces questions de
remplacabilité non remplacabilité elle
est beaucoup impact elle vient du fait
des changements dans ses compositions
donc des disparitions locales d'espèces
des modifications des interactions et ça
rejoint un peu la question des justement
des émergences de maladies qui peuvent
provenir justement de ces modifications
dans la composition de nos systèmes et
effectivement il y a des organismes qui
profitent et qui remplacent et qui
remplace parfois partiellement certaines
fonctions mais c'est justement des
organismes qui parfois
profitent bien de la crise et et avec
des conséquences aussi détriment
défavorable à l'ensemble de la
biodiversité et des services et c'est
notamment le cas des espèces
envahissantes qui est une cause majeure
du déclin de la biodiversité
donc voilà c'était pour un peu un
compléter et appuyer les propos de mon
collègue
Président vous avez
ah oui monsieur marteau va écouter
justement à ce que
ça fera le ça fera la transition avec la
séquence suivante vous êtes directeur du
de LPO France
et puis je vais vous laisser développer
mais bon le deuxième la deuxième table
ronde
nous proposer de nous pencher sur les
milieux et sur les espèces qui sont plus
spécialement vulnérables au changement
climatique dont la transition va se
faire automatiquement et je présenterai
ensuite les les deux autres intervenants
dont l'un est en visioconférence
merci beaucoup le rapporteur mesdames et
Messieurs les parlementaires merci pour
cette invitation peut-être à vendre
prendre la parole sur la deuxième table
ronde juste dire l'importance de la
diversité et de la relation entre la
diversité et les zones il y a un très
beau film très grand public mais mais
non partisan et scientifique s'appelle
la fabrique des pandémies tu es un très
bel outil de communication qui tient en
forme sur la relation entre
l'effondrement de la biodiversité et
l'apparition des maladies ça a été dit à
deux reprises mais je pense qu'il faut
vraiment insister on est ici en France
en Europe d'une manière générale dans la
plus grosse crise jamais connue de h50
une économie dans les territoires qui
aujourd'hui met à mal toute une partie
de la faune sauvage et on voit bien
comment ces zones pourrait à terme
limiter tout ce que nous sommes de
manière je veux dire dans mais aussi
dans nos schémas de construction
économique de fonctionnement sociétaux
etc et je pense que plus la diversité
sera forte et plus les écosystèmes
pourront lutter c'est très largement
publié et je pense qu'il faut vraiment
en prendre en tenir compte
ce que vous souhaitez un rapporteur que
je présente directement la passer la
deuxième table ronde enfin moi je vais
je vais parler de Monsieur
Andréas dupouet qui est chercheur à
livre mère
qui s'intéresse à l'éco physiologie
animale lié au changement entre pic et
notre troisième Intervenance sera un
girondin Monsieur Benoît Sautour
professeur
université de Bordeaux qui a publié
l'année dernière un livre sur l'estuaire
de la Gironde je pense que il est
également
en ligne ou en visio
nous nous allons peut-être commencer par
vous comme ça vous si vous êtes si vous
êtes là
vous m'entendez vous ne voyez
je vous entends et je vous vois on ne
voit pas pour l'instant bah ça y est
c'est fait
très bien alors vous
allez peut-être vous présenter et puis
on vous voulez qu'on commence par par
Monsieur Sautour ça vous va très bien
donc allez-y rentrée directement dans le
vif du sujet
merci Madame bonjour mesdames
de la Gironde un peu du tout d'accord
je vous remercie pour cette invitation
alors dans la présentation que je vais
vous faire j'ai essayé de faire un mix
entre le titre général de cette session
espèce est milieu vulnérable et puis cet
écosystème de l'estuaire de la Gironde
pris comme exemple pour illustrer
certains points
vous verrez qu'au début j'enfonce
quelques portes ouvertes mais c'est pour
arriver à des choses qui me paraissent
assez intéressantes et qui questionnent
parfois les les personnes dans les
territoires auxquelles on parle de ce
qui est en train de se passer
alors le conseil il a été fait par mes
collègues précédemment le changement
climatique induit un certain nombre de
modifications de l'environnement de
température qui augmente le cycle de
l'eau qui est modifiée des habitats qui
sont dégradés en raison de ces
changements mais aussi pour d'autres
raisons qui sont liées à l'activité
humaine et cette biodiversité elle peut
avoir des réponses variées de manière
simple les organismes qui ne peuvent pas
s'adapter meurent ou quelquefois ils
sont fragilisés et meurent pour d'autres
raisons combinées par exemple la
présence de pathogènes c'est la photo
que j'ai utilisée ici pour illustrer ce
point là le forêt qui est en train de
dépérir d'autres organismes migrent j'ai
pris comme exemple ici cet algues qui
s'appelle ostéoptiste est une algue
tropicale d'origine tropicale qu'on a
trouvé en Méditerranée depuis assez
longtemps qui a été signalé sur le
littoral atlantique il y a une quinzaine
d'années par l'Ifremer et qu'on trouve
maintenant sur les côtes du Pays Basque
dans les zones de plage mais qui pose
problème parce que c'est une algue qui
est toxique elle aimait des aérosols qui
posent des problèmes aux voies
respiratoires et donc c'est un organisme
qui pose question du point de vue de la
santé humaine sur nos côtes à l'heure
actuelle qui est en train de remonter
vers le monde
et puis d'autres organismes s'adaptent
alors on ça vous l'avez très
probablement vu cette adaptation elle
peut être liée à des développements
anticipés photos que je vous ai mis ici
développant anticiper de la végétation
par exemple
qui n'est pas toujours sans effet sur
cette végétation parce que cette
végétation qui se développe plus tôt et
soumise au gel ce qui
est quelquefois perçu de manière assez
étonnante j'avais été questionnée par
une personne à qui discutait sur le
pourquoi du nombre de jours de gel plus
importants que l'on aurait à l'heure
actuelle par rapport à ce qu'on a eu
dans le passé en fait on a des jours de
jeunes qui diminuent en nombre mais
comme la végétation se développe plutôt
bien les soumises à un gel vous pourrez
qualifier tardif si ce n'est qu'il ne
l'est pas par rapport date habituel
et puis on a aussi des adaptations
génétiques
alors deux exemples de modifications
actuels on en a déjà parlé illustre avec
ces deux diapositives qui vont venir les
déplacements c'est-à-dire des organismes
qui
ont besoin de rester dans le leurs
optimum de développement notamment dans
leurs optimums thermiques chez ceci avec
des cartes de végétation c'est deux
premières 4 et nous montrent l'évolution
de la présence du être
entre l'époque actuelle et puis
2100 ce qui vous est représenté ici
c'est la probabilité de croiser à être
si vous vous promenez sur un territoire
quand on est dans le bleu la probabilité
est faible quand on est dans les
couleurs de la probabilité est forte et
on voit que à l'horizon 2100 ce végétal
qui est associé à des zones humides des
fraîches disparait d'un certain nombre
de territoires et dans des territoires
où il est actuellement fortement
représentés mais elle devient beaucoup
plus rare c'est le cas par exemple du
Massif Central
alors ces végétaux migrent vers le nord
disparaissent de certaines zones et donc
vont être remplacées entre guillemets
par d'autres
car d'autres travaillent qui a été fait
par l'inrae Météo France où on voit les
évolutions de cortège végétaux
entre l'époque actuelle et la fin du
siècle 2100 alors si vous regardez bien
la zone rouge là c'est la végétation
méditerranéenne on sait où elle est à
l'heure actuelle bien en 2100 la région
de Bordeaux autour de Bordeaux quand on
ira se promener on se promènera dans une
végétation de kit méditerranéen et à
Paris quand on ira se promener autour de
Paris en forêt et on se promènera dans
une végétation qui ressemble à ce que
l'on a à l'heure actuelle dans le
sud-ouest de la France
donc des déplacements et puis du fait
des évolutions de température avec des
températures plus chaudes plutôt dans
l'année et plus chaude un peu plus tard
dans l'année plus chaude plutôt dans
l'année mais on a des développements qui
se font plutôt chez illustrer ceci avec
le un exemple de tiré de travaux de
collecte de l'inrae et qui ont travaillé
sur le frêne et sur d'autres végétaux
avec cette courbe qui vous montre le
jour de débourrement après le premier
janvier quand on est dans tes
températures froides et en Inde gourmand
qui est tardif quand on est dans des
températures chaudes on a un dévurement
qui est plus précoce or on est dans une
situation où on a des évolutions de
température importantes au printemps
notamment mais bon on a des
débourrements donc un développement un
début de développement des végétaux qui
se fait plutôt dans dans l'année
pour beaucoup de d'organismes
alors quand on regarde ces deux exemples
de modifications biodiversité liées au
climat il y en a beaucoup d'autres mais
je n'ai choisi que c'est de là on a
l'impression et ça a été évoqué tout à
l'heure qu'on a quelque part une
redistribution de la biodiversité une
espèce disparaît l'autre apparaît bon on
a un peu de décalage dans les cycles de
développement ou est-ce qu'on a est-ce
qu'on peut réduire ce qui est en train
de se passer uniquement à une
redistribution je le dis comme ça parce
que c'est quelquefois des choses que
l'on entend dans des débats grand public
ou pas d'ailleurs
alors c'est pas vraiment uniquement ça
puisque on n'est pas tous logés à la
même enseigne alors je l'ai illustré ici
avec des exemples d'organismes qui pour
certains sont dans des milieux extrêmes
on va dire
la réorganisation de biodiversité pour
les écosystèmes associés à la banquise
par exemple ça va être une sacrée
organisation avec des organismes qui
vont voir leur écosystème disparaître et
certains qui se qui sont très
probablement voués à disparaître assez
rapidement sauf s'il arrive à s'adapter
ce qui sera pas simple pour tout le
monde
ça c'est l'exemple de milieux extrême
pour le Nord
exemple de milieu extrême pour une zone
qui est un peu plus au sud en milieu
tropical je voulais illustrer ici avec
un exemple pour les prises de pêche sous
les tropiques ils empêchent que l'on a à
l'heure actuelle alors les poissons sont
orange ou rouge parce que c'est pour
indiquer qu'on a affaire plutôt à des
organismes qui sont thermophiles
c'est-à-dire qu'ils aiment bien les
autres
en 2000 vous voyez qu'on a perdu dans
ces zones là certains poissons ils sont
en train de remonter vers le nord ça se
réchauffe il remonte vers le nord dans
l'hémisphère nord pour rester dans le ce
qu'on appelle leur niche thermique et
puis dans le futur vous voyez qu'il en
reste plus beaucoup alors il reste
quelques espèces beaucoup ont migrés
ces quelques espèces il y a peut-être
que certaines d'entre elles réussiront à
résister et à s'adapter mais on voit une
on est en fait au tout début du
tapis roulant si on veut dire et donc on
n'a pas d'espèces pour pour remplacer ce
qui entre parenthèses posent la question
de l'utilisation de cette ressources
nutritive par certains pays qui sont par
ailleurs en difficulté pour leurs
ressources industrielles y compris sur
le continent
voilà pour des extrêmes mais sur nos
territoires on pourrait se dire on est
entre les deux on voit pas que c'est les
espèces l'une arrive elle remplace pas
tout va bien
sur nos territoires on a aussi des
espèces qui sont très directement
menacées des espèces qui sont associées
à des environnements de petites tailles
ou plus ou moins grande taille mais
voilà relativement petite des
environnements qui sont fragmentés j'ai
pris exemple ici des d'organismes qui
vivent dans des tourbières avec cette
libellule qui est une relique une espèce
relique une espèce paléohartique donc
elle vit dans ses environnements là elle
ne peut pas vivre ailleurs à proximité
de ces environnements elle est associée
au tourbières donc environnement frais
humide
et cette photo là ça représente une
sous-espèce qui est une sous-espèce qui
est endémique qui vend de la Madeleine
et donc cette sous-espèce là dans les
conditions actuelles les tourbières sont
en train de souffrir cette sous-espèces
est une sous-espèce qui est amenée à
disparaître assez rapidement si tenter
que les cette évolution se poursuit ce
qu'elle aide scanner d'être le cas
qui permet d'alimenter les poussins
Oignies on a un envol de 5 ou 6 poussins
en bonne forme à la fin de cet élevage
là au moment où les chenilles se
transforment en falaise qui ne sont plus
utilisés
c'est la situation historique ce que
l'on voit à certains endroits c'est une
chute de la population de mésanges et
les collègues qui se sont intéressés à
ça notamment au Pays-Bas ont remarqué
que du fait du réchauffement actuel les
bourgeons des bourses plutôt se
développe plutôt les chenilles ont
réussi à anticiper aussi donc elle se
développe aussi plutôt mais comme il
fait plus chaud elle se développe sur un
temps moins longue alors développement
est accéléré du fait de cette hausse de
température et au Pays-Bas les mésanges
n'ont pas réussi à décaler donc elle se
elle pondent toujours au même moment ou
un petit peu avant mais le décalage
n'est pas de même amplitude et donc on
se retrouve dans une situation où
pendant l'élevage des poussins au lit on
a une période durant laquelle le
ressources alimentaires est insuffisante
et donc on a un nombre de jeunes qui
s'envolent qui est beaucoup moins
important
moyenne de poussins qui s'envolent par
rapport à 5 ou 6
alors notre perception de ceci c'est des
choses qui ont été aussi évoqués un
petit peu précédemment on parle beaucoup
on parle beaucoup de phénomènes que l'on
peut observer qui sont vraiment
emblématiques on a parlé tout à l'heure
des coraux de leur disparition liées à
la température liée à l'acidification
des océans à certains endroits on a
parlé aussi de la fonte des calottes ou
de la forme de la banquise alors j'ai
pris ici un exemple
est assez bien documenté que le grand
public connaît au moins pour partie bon
les glaces continentales fontent la
banquise font aussi vous avez ici un
graphique entre l'évolution de la masse
de la calotte groenlandaise que j'ai
pris comme exemple
et ces phénomènes très généraux qui sont
assez bien documentés ont des
conséquences locales qui sont très
concrètes donc j'arrive petit à petit à
l'estuaire de la Gironde
on a des eaux continentales qui fendent
on a de plus une extension thermique des
eaux
océaniques et donc on a une montée du
niveau marin ce qui induit sur les
littoraux une érosion plus ou moins
importante
l'érosion qu'on a à l'heure actuelle due
au climat qui se combine à une érosion
naturelle sur le littoral atlantique qui
est lié à un déficit de sable en mer qui
fait que cette érosion se fait aussi du
fait de ce processus là et puis des
risques de submersion qui s'accroisent
du fait de cette montée du niveau marin
mais aussi du fait de l'augmentation de
fréquence d'un certain nombre de
phénomènes extrêmes
alors il me semble que Philippe
grandcolla l'a dit tout à l'heure on a
une perte de dans l'avenir on s'attend à
une perte importante des littoraux donc
disparition d'écosystèmes littoraux
disparition biodiversité qui aurait
associé salinisation des masses d'eau
mais aussi des choses qui concernent
très directement la sécurité des
personnes et des biens ce que je viens
de d'évoquer notamment des risques de
subversion ça vous rappelle peut-être
des événements assez dramatiques Xya il
y a peu obsécurité des personnes et des
biens ça envoie à des questions de
déplacement de population qui commence à
être abordés à certains endroits y
compris chez nous pas que dans les îles
du Pacifique
et puis ça questionne aussi notre
utilisation du littoral en termes de
zone de production en termes de
transport de développement urbain etc
alors des conséquences locales très
concrètes ou beaucoup plus discrète que
l'on ne perçoit pas ça a été évoqué tout
à l'heure aussi
localement en 30 ans dans l'estuaire de
la Gironde le milieu physico-chimique a
évolué avec une salinité de deux unités
en plus à l'intérieur de l'estuaire et
une température de 2 degrés en plus ce
qu'on a ce qu'on a gagné entre
guillemets en 30 ans avec un une
problématique particulière au niveau de
Bordeaux les sueur de la Gironde c'est
un estuaire qui est très chargé en
particulier
au dessus sur les ponts là vous avez une
couleur très marrante il y a beaucoup de
particules dans l'eau
et cette quantité de particules
associées à une augmentation de
température induit depuis un certain
nombre d'années des déficits en oxygène
au niveau de la ville de Bordeaux donc
la température augmente et puis on a la
déficit
assez récurrentes
alors qu'est-ce qui se passe pour la
biodiversité alors des évolutions qui
sont beaucoup plus discrètes parce que
ces évolutions se sont des évolutions
qui ne sont pas graduelles elles ne sont
pas constantes on voit des changements
abrupt des accélérations et puis les
décélérations des périodes d'instabilité
aux évolutions assez
ératiques ces évolutions elles sont
liées notamment aux indices climatiques
à grande échelle je vous ai illustrer
ceci ici avec un graphe qui vous montre
les évolutions de température et ici un
graphe qui vous montre les évolutions de
communauté du poisson on voit pas de
diminution graduelle ou de
d'augmentation gravure
entre ces changements abruptes on a des
modifications qui sont notoires je vous
ai illustrer ça ici avec le travail d'un
jeune collègue vous aviez Chevillot là
qui a travaillé sur ces sur ces
évolutions non graduelles ponctuées par
des ce qu'on appelle des chiffres à
bruts avec un chiffre en 88 avant 88 on
avait surtout des poissons Enfield les
poissons en fila ce sont des poissons
qui laissent sur le continent et puis
qui vont aller se développer en mer vous
voyez de 88 au début des années 2000 on
a une période d'instabilité on sait pas
très bien comment ça varie et puis à
partir du milieu des années 2000 la
communauté de poissons en fialin a
fortement diminué et la communauté de
poissons marins a fortement augmenté
dans l'estuaire de la Gironde
a des conséquences sur le fonctionnement
de l'estuaire que je vais illustrer avec
un réseau trophique qui est très
simplifié avec un pull nutritif dans
lequel on va trouver des micro-algues
c'est assez classique et puis comme on a
un environnement qui est très chargé en
particulier on a aussi du matériel des
critiques qui sert aussi de base au
réseau trophiques accompagné de
bactéries qui le
secours nutritif il est consommé comme
habituellement en milieu littoral par
des organismes de plantes ont et puis
par des organismes bâti
des huîtres par exemple les mots et puis
j'ai pris ici d'autres illustrations
avec un verre ici une ambival depuis une
crevette qu'on voit pas bien elle est
bien camouflée dans son environnement et
ces organismes-là sont des organismes
qui sont consommés par les représentants
de la communauté de poissons
alors quelles sont les modifications
qu'on peut observer à l'heure actuelle
pour ces différents compartiments
alors pour les autres plancton mais on a
des effectifs stables
mais on a des espèces invasives qui
arrivent comme comme pour d'autres
compartiments et comme à beaucoup
d'autres endroits parmi ces espèces
invasives qui arrivent beaucoup de
représentants de ce qu'on appelle le
plancton gélatineux
plancton qui a un aspect que j'ai
là-dessus des méduses par exemple
donc cette espèce là qui n'est pas une
méduse mais qui est un organisme
c'est une espèce qui est originaire des
côtes américaines qui est apparu dans
les années 80-90 en mer Noire et en mer
Caspienne et qui est un vrai aspirateur
à zooplan un super prédateur du
zooplancton quand on la voit consommer
c'est un tapis roulant
et vous voyez que ce zooplancton il est
consommé aussi par lithiophones si vous
avez ici un aspirateur à zooplancton
mais ça veut dire que le flux
vernisiophone au conflit qui va
forcément diminuer c'est ce qui s'est
passé en mer Noire en mer Caspienne et
ce qui est amené à la disparition de
certaines pêcheries par épuisement du
stock de poisson pêché épuisement lié à
cette appauvrissement de nourriture
l'unan liée à la consommation par ce qui
était arrivé dans cette zone là
et c'est la première fois qu'ils avaient
été observés de ce côté-ci de
l'Atlantique
entre le zooplancton et lithiophones
qu'est-ce qu'on observe dans l'observe
une désynchronisation comme celle que
l'on a vu pour les maisons Charbonnières
que leur désynchronisation entre les
proies et les prédateurs
c'est au climat le bentos envoie une
baisse drastique du effectifs
probablement lié à plusieurs causes mais
on n'a pas bien sûr encore des
identifier parce qu'on n'a pas de série
suffisamment longues et puis on voit
l'arrivée des espèces exotiques et pour
les poissons qu'est-ce qu'on observe
mais on observe une diminution de la
présence des espèces enfyaline c'est lié
à un certain nombre de problématiques
locales
surexploitation locale ou bien sûr
exploitation en milieu marin ça peut
être aussi surexploitation sur le bassin
versant sur le bassin versant
destruction des frayères fragmentation
de l'habitacle qualité de l'eau qui
diminue etc donc ces espèces là
diminuent on diminue de manière
extrêmement importante à l'intérieur de
l'estuaire de la Gironde ce qui est
signe d'une qualité d'un environnement
qui s'est dégradé depuis le bassin
versant jusqu'au milieu marin
et puis les espèces marines les ont
entre guillemets remplacées ce qui n'est
pas signe d'une qualité d'une bonne
qualité de l'environnement ce qui est
juste signe d'une marinisation de
l'environnement c'est à dire que
l'estuaire c'est s'aligner ça a permis
la pénétration de ces espèces marines
dans dans l'estuelle
donc voilà vous voyez des
choses qui ne sont pas qui ne sont pas
aussi marqués aussi facilement
médiatisable que l'ours blanc je vous ai
montré sur son glaçon tout à l'heure on
a du mal à faire le buzz avec du
zooplancton et une espèce invasive qui
arrive à un endroit donné néanmoins
l'ensemble de ces de ces modifications
fait que à l'heure actuelle on est dans
une situation où la capacité trophique
de cette estuaire comme d'autres est en
train de diminuer ce sont des zones qui
sont historiquement connues pour avoir
une capacité de trophique c'est à dire
pour être des réserves de des
garde-manger de nourriture pour les
poissons qui viennent s'y reproduire les
jeunes
dancer en milieu marin ou vers le milieu
continental il y a cette capacité de
trophique est en train de chuter ce qui
questionne pour les poissons marins qui
viennent dans les jeunes viennent se
développer dans cet environnement sac
estone leur croissance et donc leur
survie en mer et très directement sa
question aussi les stocks de poissons
qu'on retrouve dans le golf de Gascogne
et donc l'activité de pêche
qui se trouve face à cette difficulté là
qui n'est pas la seule qui est aussi
efface une difficulté qui est liée aux
migrations des poissons habituellement
pêchés qui sont des poissons qui
vers le nord ça pose question sur les
limites des zones de pêche etc
vous voyez des modifications plus
discrètes mais finalement qui amène à
des choses qui sont assez importantes
d'un point de vue
environnemental pour les espèces de fin
de chaîne mais aussi socio-économique du
point de vue de l'exploitation que l'on
peut faire de cette ressource
voilà j'en arrive à ma conclusion le
climat et les autres pressions
anthropiques que l'on est en train de
subir à l'heure actuelle amen a des
conséquences qui sont visibles qui sont
souvent documentées puis à d'autres qui
sont beaucoup plus discrètes qui sont
attachés quelquefois ce qu'on appelle la
biodiversité ordinaire quand il a été
question précédemment et l'ensemble
participe à ce que l'on est en train de
dire c'est à dire un effondrement actuel
de la biodiversité que chez illustré ici
avec ce graphe nous représente
l'évolution de l'indice Planet vivante
qui correspond à des résultats qui
regroupent des données sur un peu plus
de 4000 espèces et plusieurs dizaines de
milliers de populations de ces espèces
effondrement de biodiversité actuelle
qui a des conséquences socio-économiques
que j'ai illustré avec cette exemple de
la pêche mais qui a déjà été parmi
connectes précédemment avec d'autres
exemples
je vous remercie pour votre
participation merci beaucoup moi j'ai
participé à une réunion de crise à au
port d'Arcachon à la criée ou le stock
de sol à diminuer de façon qu'on a donné
des quotas maintenant au pêcheur et qui
permettent leur permettre à peine de
vivre je vais passer la parole puisqu'on
l'a interrompu tout à l'heure pour
présenter ce tour je vais parler passé
la parole à Monsieur Cédric marteau
vous avez
écouté monsieur Sautour qui nous a parlé
de la maison charbonnière donc c'est un
lien qui est qui me vient à l'esprit là
pour vous donner la parole et de vous
écouter
merci beaucoup alors effectivement moi
je vais faire vraiment un zoom je vais
on va rester en nouvelle Aquitaine et on
va parler plutôt des Pertuis des Pertuis
charentés à la question quelle espèce
sont les plus vulnérables aujourd'hui et
si je ne parle que le compartiment
oiseau au niveau mondial ce sont les
perroquets perruches on est peu
concernés ensuite viennent les oiseaux
marins on est très concernés à l'échelle
de l'Europe très concerné en France et
c'est lié principalement interactions
avec les pêcheries et aujourd'hui avec
l'apparition des zones sur les colonies
oiseaux marins sont le compartiment des
oiseaux qui chutent le plus au niveau
mondial au niveau européen et au niveau
français mais mon propos va
et puis ensuite pardon vient les oiseaux
des plaines agricoles et ça c'est
typiquement c'est une caractéristique en
France métropolitaine
ce sont les oiseaux des plaines
agricoles les oiseaux communs l'alouette
des champs très très oiseaux très très
communs très populaires
35% de diminution sur les 15 dernières
années les chardonnerets chardonnerai
les dents 38% de diminution sur les 10
dernières années sont des oiseaux
extrêmement communs qui sont liés
au milieu agricole les outardes aussi et
avec une pression principale qui sont
les phytosanitaires
trémie en avant dans toutes les
publications scientifiques et certaines
molécules de produits chimiques mon
propos va se concentrer sur le lien
changement climatique et population
d'oiseaux j'espérais avoir le powerpoint
mais j'ai l'impression que ça va être
difficile
bon je vais sortir le l'ordi et je l'ai
sur mon ordi vous dire
vous le savez on est en pleine période
de migration des oiseaux aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui même on a des dizaines des
centaines de milliers d'oiseaux qui
traversent la France ils viennent de
Scandinavie ils viennent d'Europe de
l'Est de robes de l'ouest ils se sont
reproduits et puis pour passer l'hiver
ils vont descendre en Afrique du Nord au
Sahel et en Afrique de l'ouest ils font
ce trajet deux fois par an en ce moment
même en ce moment les oiseaux descendent
sur leur quartier divers et puis vont
revenir au printemps les hirondelles
sont déjà partis ils sont partis en
juillet
juste en septembre les martinets sont
partis les premiers Martinet qui sont à
Paris ou dans notre grande ville sont
partis dès le mois de juillet ces
oiseaux pour faire ce trajet ont besoin
de faire des haltes de migration comme
nous lorsqu'on nous partons en vacances
on a besoin de faire des pauses c'est
plein d'essence de la même manière ils
ont besoin de retrouver de l'énergie et
donc ces oiseaux vont s'arrêter dans des
secteurs côtiers notamment que la France
ses vertus de protéger depuis des années
par différents classements et notamment
par les réserves naturelles nationales
qui depuis politique publique qui marche
très bien depuis les années 70 on crée
des réserves naturelles nationales de
plus en plus des réserves naturelles
régionales puisque les régions
compétences également pour créer ces
outils et ces oiseaux vont venir
s'arrêter en très grand nombre dans ces
réserves naturelles certains vont y
rester parce que les conditions ils sont
favorables et on va avoir des
concentrations d'oiseaux représentant
j'en prendrai qu'une que la réserve de
moins Oléron donc on est situé dans le
pertuis on est en dessous de l'île de Ré
on est tout près de l'île d'Oléron la
réserve touche l'île d'Oléron et va
juste à la partie continentale sur la
commune de
c'est une réserve qui fait 6500 hectares
donc on est sur quelque chose d'assez
réduit et cette réserve va accueillir
100 000 oiseaux 100 000 oiseaux c'est
11% de la population de ces oiseaux
entre la Scandinavie et le Maroc donc
vous voyez un 10% se concentre dans dans
cette zone
ce qui se passe et ça a été rappelé par
par notre collègue juste avant
évidemment on subit de plein fouet le
changement climatique
la fonte des galettes des calottes
glaciaires article Antarctique et la
dilatation de la molécule d'eau faite
les océans augmentent on a un constat
très
chiffré dans les pertuis et on prend de
plus en plus de dépression de système de
tempête merci beaucoup pour la
présentation je vais la diapo 3
merci donc diapo 3 juste avant je vais
voilà
j'espère que ça va fonctionner
fonctionne pas mais c'est pas très grave
donc voilà la cartographie on est on est
dans les pertuis
Île de Ré il d'Oléron je vous l'ai dit
dans les pourcentages très grosse
concentration d'oiseaux
et si je zoome sur
la réserve de mouest est-ce que l'on
voit on voit une augmentation du niveau
de la mer vous avez la courbe de
tendance quelques millimètres certes
mais des dépressions de plus en plus
fortes tout le monde évidemment se
rappelle de la tempête Cynthia Cynthia
une des dernières grandes catastrophes
de notre pays il y a eu avant la tempête
Martin depuis il y a eu la tempête
Susanna il y a eu la tempête Alex et
puis évidemment on attend la prochaine
il faut être dans la mise en évidence
toutes les climatologues nous le disent
il y a une accélération des dépression
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé concrètement
sur ce secteur on avait une digue une
digue de terre puisque en
Charente-Maritime les principales dites
sont faites avec des argiles on met des
couches d'argile depuis toujours on a
Paul dérisé les différents marées de
cette manière il a dit la céder à
plusieurs reprises à plusieurs reprises
l'état la réparer notamment avec l'aide
des collectivités jusqu'au moment où
aujourd'hui nous sommes plus en capacité
de réparer cette dite cette digue elle
est beaucoup trop ouverte et donc il a
été décidé de se laisser la digue
ouverte aujourd'hui j'étais hier sur
place il a dit il est ouvert de 320
mètres et les argiles sont en train de
partir c'est digmater la sédimentation
donc elle avait permis de maintenir le
marais il a dit en train de partir
évidemment aujourd'hui on a une arrivée
d'eau à chaque marée chaque marée l'eau
rentre dans les terres donc dans la
réserve naturelle qui était une réserve
purement terrestre une salinité qui qui
augmente et un travail travail fait par
le Conservatoire du littoral je souligne
le travail de cet établissement public
et un travail vraiment magnifique
d'acquisition foncière bien sûr un
travail financé par l'Europe via un
programme LIFE qui s'appelle adapto dans
les conclusions sont rendus à Saint-Malo
le 30 novembre prochain et le
une réflexion évidemment dans le cadre
et vous savez des des différents papis
qui sont conduits actuellement le plan
de prévention des inondations une digue
coûteuse derrière il n'y a pas de
population j'insiste en est dans des cas
de figure à chaque fois très différents
entre ce qui se passe à La
Tranche-sur-Mer aujourd'hui avec la
digue évidemment acceptée par tout ce
qui protège les populations
dans la réserve naturelle de la belle
Henriette dans la LPO est également
gestionnaire d'une situation comme
l'îloténie
Île de Ré ou de la même manière la
modélisation montre que la réserve
naturelle va être sous l'eau à
l'échéance 2040 2050 et donc là on est
aussi dans une disparition importante du
foncier de l'île de Ré avec vous
connaissez tous le foncier de l'île de
Ré le prix au mètre carré de l'île de Ré
qui va disparaître tu vas tout
simplement être submergé évidemment dans
les zones
où il y a des populations les digues ont
déjà été fait là l'état j'étais déjà 100
millions d'euros donc il y a déjà eu un
effort considérable des collectivités
bien évidemment dans la situation de
Moise on est un peu dans une situation
différente on est dans un marais ou
derrière tout est en arrêt une partie
était drainée pour être transformé en
terre agricole et les populations les
villages et bien éloigné de cette
situation donc trois choix s'offrent à
nous soit on fait du béton on fait une
digue soit on fait une nouvelle digue
mais en retrait
bien plus éloigné pour protéger la
population on est assez loin du des
villages soit on laisse faire ça vous
sera au papy évidemment dans dans
décider aujourd'hui ce qui se présente
et ma présentation est très courte parce
que l'idée c'est dans d'ouvrir un peu le
débat sur ces sujets c'est
qu'aujourd'hui dans le cas de nos
engagements européens nous avons une
obligation d'accueillir c'est halte de
migration et cela depuis la directive
oiseau 79409 et donc nous n'avons pas le
choix de trouver de nouveaux lieux de
reporter ces zones d'accueil de
ressources pour ces oiseaux
on estime évidemment que ces zones
bénéficient à plusieurs millions
d'oiseaux d'intérêts communautaires donc
quand on dit quelles sont la priorité de
protéger quelle espèce je dirais ben ces
oiseaux migrateurs sur quel type de
milieu sur les milieux où ils viennent
s'alimenter pendant leur halte de
migration on a c'est une problématique
européenne puisque évidemment tous les
pays de l'Europe sont concernés nos
collègues des Pays-Bas belges donc les
Portugais et Espagnols subissent la même
situation et nous avions réussi dans le
cadre de l'Europe à avoir cette mosaïque
d'altes de migration qui permettait
justement une efficacité de protection
de ces oiseaux migrateurs puisqu'il faut
le dire il y a aussi des bonnes
nouvelles et c'est pour ça que nous
gardons espoir votre question monsieur
sénateur tout à l'heure mais de la
science comment on fait pour
c'est vrai qu'il y a il est pas de temps
qui peuvent être différents mais il y a
aussi c'est cette morosité qui peut
apparaître lorsqu'on a des constats
comme ceux qui ont été présentés
aujourd'hui mais aussi une des signes
d'espoir il y a quantité d'oiseaux qui
vont beaucoup mieux à l'échelle de
l'Europe on a su les protéger je vais
parler de de la Sidoine blanche la
silote blanche et une espèce quasi
disparue dans les années 70 aujourd'hui
c'est une espèce très abondante en
Alsace en nouvelle-aquitaine et en
région dans différentes régions c'est
pas le cas globalement de la
biodiversité vous l'avez bien compris il
y a quand même des signaux de reprise
qui nous donnent espoir et qui montre
que si on sait agir et si on met une
polémique une politique publique et
efficace les choses peuvent se faire
aujourd'hui dans le cas précis de la
réserve de Moïse
l'objectif va être de reculer cette
réserve naturelle on peut le faire dans
ce cas précis nous pouvons le faire on
pourra pas le faire sur tous les sites
et les échanges sont en cours avec la
profession agricole il faut compenser
évidemment la profession puisque l'enjeu
sera de retransformé ces terres qui
étaient du marais qui ont été
transformés au moment dans les années 70
en terre agricole de les retransformer
en marée permettant d'accueillir et donc
de décaler à peu près de d'un kilomètre
5 de décaler à l'intérieur des terres
ces zones de protection c'est évidemment
un enjeu très fort un enjeu qui se
prépare on est sur des échanges à 2040
la profession a été au début très
réticente et puis voyant aussi la
situation péchés sont bien contents de
la d'augmentation notamment de la
salinité de leur parcelle et donc de
diminution des rendements à terme sont
plutôt dans une approche constructive
l'objectif c'est évidemment ça préserver
ces noyaux de population qui représente
une quantité d'espèces plus de plus de
350 espèces en France plusieurs
centaines font les migrations et donc
c'est un bénéfice à l'échelle de
l'ensemble des oiseaux
voilà un exemple très concret d'action
sur le territoire je vous renvoie si
merci beaucoup je vais passer la parole
à Monsieur Andréas dupouet
merci beaucoup merci pour l'invitation
moi ça va être une présentation un peu
plus rapide et un peu plus spécialisé je
pense sur ce qu'est ma discipline donc
l'éco physiologie animale et dans quelle
mesure ça peut être mis au service donc
de du maintien de la biodiversité donc
normalement j'ai un support aussi
déjà vous précisez que le que l'éco
physiologie donc c'est une discipline
récente qui a été surtout établie dans
le cours des années 2000 et qui vise
donc un caractériser les réponses
fonctionnelles des organismes qui nous
entourent donc les plantes les animaux
et de manière à comprendre comment
est-ce qu'ils vont adapter en fait leur
physiologie leur comportement aux
variations de l'environnement qui les
entoure de manière à assurer donc leur
survie et leur reproduction donc leur
persistance dans un habitat donné et
donc fort de ces de cette compréhension
donc des mécanismes fonctionnels qui
font le lien entre un animal et son
environnement on est capable de
comprendre comment est-ce qu'on en est
arrivé à la biodiversité qu'on connaît
actuellement c'est à dire comment des
espèces sont capables de coloniser des
environnements qui à nous nous
paraissent hostiles par exemple les
pôles on va l'épaule pour un ours
polaire c'est pas du tout hostile c'est
son environnement et inversement pour
les déserts et une fois qu'on connaît
les gammes de tolérance des organismes à
des gammes environnementales données on
est capable de prédire de manière plus
fiable le devenir d'une population d'une
espèce ou d'un écosystème
dans un habitat donné grâce notamment
aux prédictions qui sont émises par le
GIEC
et donc bon ça c'est les grandes causes
de déclin de la biodiversité qui ont été
rappelés au début les 5 volets majeurs
qui sont susceptibles localement
d'interagir les uns avec les autres le
réchauffement climatique est
improbablement celui qui est le plus ubi
cuisse en le il est il est présent
partout sur Terre dans des magnitudes
qui sont qui sont variables mais
néanmoins partout et qui susceptibles
d'exacerber tout un tas de de stress
d'origine anthropique et notamment de
pollution ou de surexploitation des
ressources et donc l'enjeu de nos
recherches à nous en éco-physiologie
c'est de vraiment comprendre comment ces
organismes fonctionnent en réponse à ces
stress pour en limiter les effets de du
mieux possible donc là le graphique que
j'ai que j'illustre ici c'est vous
donner un ordre de grandeur de
l'extinction de masse donc monsieur
grand-cola parlait de la sixième
extinction de masse en termes de
chiffres on est à 75% d'espèces de
vertébré terrestres qui sont aujourd'hui
menacées donc on est sur quelque chose
de majeur et de massif
tout l'enjeu de nos recherches
au alifremer mais pas que au CNRS le
rôle des chercheurs en écologie
aujourd'hui c'est de vous proposer une
compréhension et de des différentes
espèces et des milieux desquels on parle
pour prendre les meilleures décisions
que le politique soit le mieux informé
pour prendre ses décisions alors pour
vous donner un exemple très concret de
ce qu'on fait nous au laboratoire à
Brest c'est de donc reproduire ces
environnements stressants alors des
conditions de température des
expositions à des populations à des
pollutions
de la disponibilité alimentaire qui
varie nous on s'intéresse principalement
au coquillages donc les huîtres et les
moules essentiellement mais pas que qui
sont des espèces évidemment à en jeu
économiques vous le savez et donc il y a
fort à comprendre ce qui explique en
fait le devenir de ces espèces dans leur
dans leur environnement et donc de
comprendre les mécanismes qui vont
expliquer comment des nouvelles
conditions la nouvelle donne
environnementale imposée par l'homme
affecter leur croissance leur survie
leur reproduction dans un dans un
environnement donné et donc grâce à ça
et grâce au scénario climatique qui sont
émis à l'heure actuelle on connaît en
tout cas on peut estimer de manière plus
ou moins fiable les conditions de
température que seront celles de nos
latitudes donc de dans notre cas de nos
côtes et donc de prédire le devenir de
ces espèces à cet endroit là enfin
localement et donc ce qui est illustré
sur les cartes de du bas c'est que c'est
toute l'importance de comprendre en fait
et de faire de la recherche sur ces
espèces là pour comprendre comment elle
fonctionne puisque les réponses ne vont
pas être les mêmes selon l'espèce
concernée par exemple à gauche vous avez
l'huître creuse qui est une espèce
invasive sur nos côtes d'accord elle a
été introduite à la fin du siècle
dernier depuis le Japon pour des besoins
ostréicoles parce que justement on avait
éteint une autre espèce pour d'autres
raisons cette espèce elle va
vraisemblablement plutôt bénéficier du
réchauffement climatique
ce qui est illustré donc les couleurs en
fait c'est les
de croissance populationnelle plus vous
approchez du rouge plus les populations
vont augmenter et plus vous approchez du
bleu plus elles vont diminuer à droite
vous avez la moule bleue qui est une
espèce plutôt endémique qui elle au
contraire va complètement décliner à
horizon 2100 à cause de réchauffement
climatique bon bah ça pour des personnes
qui cultivent les moules et qui en
dépendent pour leur vie ça a des
conséquences mais pas que ça a des
conséquences aussi pour les écosystèmes
puisque les bivals enfin les coquillages
sont souvent des espèces ingénieurs du
milieu ils sont à l'interface ils sont
eux-mêmes des proies et des prédateurs
voilà donc c'est pour vous illustrer un
peu le l'approche qu'on utilise nous en
laboratoire à quoi on sert aujourd'hui
et bien c'est de vous d'identifier les
causes et les conséquences à venir pour
la biodiversité qu'on connaît
moi au cours de mes recherches je
m'intéresse à comprendre les mécanismes
moléculaires qui sous-tendent ces
réponses populationsnelles donc c'est
tout l'intérêt de l'éco physiologie
c'est d'être à l'interface de plusieurs
échelles d'intégration donc on est
capable de comprendre en fait comment
des stress environnementaux vont venir
impacter des fonctionnements à l'échelle
moléculaire ou cellulaire de ces
organismes et notamment donc c'est
l'exemple que je prends là que sont le
vieillissement de ces de ces coquillages
que nous on mesure à travers un
indicateur que qu'on appelle les
télomères qui sont présents en fait aux
extrémités des chromosomes donc les
huîtres les moules en ont mais vous
aussi d'accord tout le monde vieillit
ici
voilà les huîtres vieillissent et ce
vieillissement il peut être accéléré il
peut être accéléré par tout un tas de
stress environnementaux vous ça va être
le tabagisme les huîtres ça va être le
réchauffement bon bah le réchauffement
quand il quand il s'intensifie il est
susceptible d'accélérer le
vieillissement de ces organismes qui via
ces télomère en fait qui vont être
impactés également à travers la lignée
germinale donc sur les gamètes se
transmettre aux générations suivantes
ces générations suivantes vont donc
partir avec un capital vieillissement
plus faible que la génération d'avant et
à mesure étant donné que le
réchauffement climatique ne va pas aller
en se ralentissant à mesure que les
stress climatiques vont devenir
chronique on s'attend en fait à un
emballement du système et avoir des
juvéniles qui naîtront très peu
résilient face à toute autre stress
environnementale et donc passer un point
de bascule vers le déclin des
populations alors je vois votre tête
madame la rapportrice c'est pas quelque
chose de d'irréversible c'est tout
l'intérêt en fait de ces recherches
qu'on mène sur ces organismes de
comprendre les mécanismes on est capable
de les éviter les télomères
il y a toute une batterie d'enzymes qui
sont susceptibles de les réparer donc si
on prend le temps de comprendre comment
les espèces fonctionnent on est capable
de prendre le temps aussi de trouver les
solutions qui sont les plus adéquates ce
qui m'amène à ma dernière diapositive
des projets qui sont menés en fait au
sein de l'ifère et qui sont tout à fait
encourageants sur l'huître plate huitre
plate c'est notre espèce indigène à nous
d'accord qui était présente sur nos
côtes historiquement qu'on a décimé
mais qui est introduite aujourd'hui par
Stéphane Pouvreau notamment donc en rade
de Brest qui est une espèce qui forme
des récifs donc des récifs qui n'ont pas
grand chose à envier au récif corallien
de la Nouvelle-Calédonie c'est une
espèce qui va structurer une
biodiversité absolument remarquable et
les premiers travaux de réintroduction
montrer des résultats assez
poussouflants sur les espèces qui sont
capables qui dépendent en fait de cette
espèce pour pour vivre et pour se
développer donc un message qui est
relativement encourageant si tenté qu'on
s'inquiète et qu'on apporte des
connaissances à des acteurs locaux sur
les décisions qui seront prises grâce à
la connaissance des scientifiques on est
capable de prendre des mesures de
conservation qui sont tout à fait
adéquates et faire confiance à la
résilience des écosystèmes pour pour
reprendre le dessus donc voilà je vais
finir sur ce message un peu un peu
positif même si évidemment
la résilience ne fait pas tout et qu'on
poussait le système jusqu'à un point de
bascule peut avoir des conséquences
irrémédiable
merci beaucoup je suis assez âgé pour
avoir connu l'huître plate
du bassin d'Arcachon
mais j'avais
compris que c'était que c'est une espèce
qui avait disparu à cause d'une d'une
zone d'une virose il y a plusieurs
causes en fait c'est des causes toujours
c'est toujours pareil c'est complexe le
monde du vivant est complexe interactif
c'est une espèce qui historiquement a
été très consommée et dont on utilisait
les coquilles par exemple pour faire des
talus donc ce qui était vraiment une
espèce extrêmement abondante mais qui a
été qui a fait les frais en fait de la
surexploitation qui a perdu en effectif
ces effectifs plus faibles la moindre
maladie arrive et place on détruit le
système on a moins en fait à perdre des
individus on perd la capacité justement
de résilience la probabilité de tomber
sur quelques individus qui vont être
résistants de la même manière que
certains êtres humains sont résistants
au covid certaines huîtres plates
pouvaient être résistantes à ces zones
et on disparu à que ça puisqu'on en
avait pas on en avait pas le patrimoine
génétique et ce pourquoi la biodiversité
et c'est ce qui a été mentionné s'exerce
à trois échelles à l'échelle génétique
individuelle et écosystémiques c'est
l'intégration de ces trois niveaux
d'intégration qui nous permet d'avoir
quelque chose de stable dans le temps
donc je sais pas si mes collègues ont
des questions moi pour approfondir ces
histoires d'huîtres là pour connaître un
peu le milieu austréiculteur
j'ai je vois ce qui se passe
actuellement certains
ostriculteurs vont investir sur des
exploitations en Normandie par exemple
ou dans le de manière à pouvoir
pérenniser leur activité c'est c'est
une adaptation mais c'est vrai que
j'avais pas entendu parler de la
plateaux
l'espèce cultivée essentiellement par
les ostréiculteurs bien qu'il y ait des
cultures du trop-palate sur dans
différents environnements c'est des
huîtres qui vont beaucoup voyager au
cours de leur vie on a des captations de
dessin donc de larves d'huîtres qui se
font essentiellement dans le pertuis
charentais
ou qui sont générés par des centres de
[Musique]
silicone les CRC
et qui vont donc alimenter enfin qui
vont que les que les ostréiculteurs vont
acheter qui vont après déplacer à
différents endroits de nos côtes donc en
Normandie pour la croissance puis qui
vont les ramener après par exemple sur
les temps de taux ou dans ces zones là
pour pour les affiner dans le Marine
d'Oléron notamment dans les dans les
films de Claire pour elles ne passent
que très peu de temps en fait dans ces
zones là en fait elles ont elles ont
grandi à d'autres endroits donc une
empreinte écologique qui est quand même
assez assez importante elles sont
déplacées
l'huître plate il y a
à l'heure actuelle bon moi je suis pas
spécialiste de ce qu'est l'ostréiculture
et de ce monde là je ça fait un an que
je suis recruté à l'Ifremer d'accord
donc moi je m'intéresse avant je
travaillais sur les reptiles moi ce qui
m'intéresse c'est l'éco physiologie de
ces organismes c'est leur réponse en
fait au changement qui leur sont imposés
ce que je peux vous dire c'est ce que je
me présentais là c'est que du moment
qu'on comprend le temps et qu'on
s'intéresse en fait à la préservation de
de ces récifs huitres plates historiques
on met les moyens en œuvre pour
comprendre leur fonctionnement mais
aussi pour en assurer le maintien et la
pérennité en protégeant l'écosystème aux
alentours on y arrive et ça non
seulement on y arrive mais on retrouve
des taux de recrutement l'arvère qui
sont qui sont proches de ceux qu'on
aurait pu connaître historiquement donc
c'est quand même encourageant
absolument je pense que mes collègues
ont des questions Philippe bolo merci
même le rapporteur
deux questions s'il vous plaît qui ont
peut-être s'adresser à Monsieur marteau
et Monsieur grandcola la première
question on a compris au travers de vos
présentations que l'homme était le
responsable d'un certain nombre de
déséquilibres qui explique les pertes de
biodiversité cependant la relation de
l'homme et de la nature est ancienne et
sur des temps longs et à des époques où
il y avait pas le réchauffement
climatique où les dynamiques temporelles
étaient beaucoup plus lentes et
d'ailleurs vous l'avez parfaitement
démontré monsieur marteau dans le
l'exemple que vous avez donné avec la
digue qui vient à rompre et qui montrait
que finalement l'action de l'homme avait
été profitable à la création d'un
écosystème favorable aux oiseaux et donc
la question va être la suivante alors
que nous sommes dans un contexte
d'érosion de la biodiversité que nous
avons tous des actions à mener pour
lutter contre cette rose érosion là il y
a quand même dans le même même temps un
certain nombre de
décision à prendre sur des aménagements
sur des politiques à mener qui tiennent
compte de cette perspective de lutter
contre l'érosion de la biodiversité mais
qui m'interroge sur le point suivant
c'est à dire est-ce que parfois dans nos
raisonnements on regarde l'étude
d'impact c'est à dire qu'on va regarder
qu'est-ce que ça va avoir quand même pas
sur une biodiversité qui est elle-même
et déjà sur une trajectoire défavorable
mais vous avez démontré que parfois
l'action de l'homme pouvait être
favorable et donc comment peut-on dans
les décisions nous avons à prendre qui
sont des décisions d'aménagement de
politique publique tenir compte pas de
l'impact mais du bénéfice que peuvent
apporter certaines de nos de nos de nos
décisions sur la biodiversité à des
échelles de temps qui sont longues et
donc en définitive comment doit-on tenir
compte du référentiel qui est le
référentiel ancien et le référentiel
présent pour prendre des décisions alors
qu'on a un référentiel futur qu'on ne
connaît pas encore complètement et que
sur lequel on pourra avoir une action
positive ça c'était ma première question
et ma deuxième question va être la
directement pour Monsieur marteau je
vais faire le lien avec la commission
des affaires économiques de l'Assemblée
nationale où je suis
co-rapporteur avec Charles Fournier
député de tours d'une mission
d'information sur la grippe aviaire
comment doit-on lire la cohabitation de
trois écosystèmes en lien avec ce sujet
de la grippe aviaire qui sont d'un côté
un écosystème enfin une biodiversité
d'élevage des des volailles d'élevage de
l'autre côté des oiseaux migrateurs et
entre les deux
un virus qui vient créer un déséquilibre
dans laquelle quels sont les grandes
façons de lire cette interaction et donc
les décisions qu'on doit prendre pour
que finalement
ces décisions soient positives tendent
du point de vue de l'élevage que de la
biodiversité des oiseaux migrateurs je
vous remercie
est-ce qu'en gel previl veut poser sa
question en même temps parce que ça
ou est-ce qu'on répond directement là on
est plus que plus très nombreux donc en
vous pouvez répondre en direct c'est pas
plus mal
pour répondre à la première question en
fait effectivement on a besoin d'avoir
connaissance d'une tendance sur le temps
long et puis pouvoir après se focaliser
enfin réduire notre échelle des à des
moments dans le temps qui sont plus
courts donc pour pouvoir réagir sans
négliger pour autant les conséquences à
long terme alors ça suppose l'existence
d'un référentiel donc le référentiel
autant très long ou temps historique
c'est les sciences de la Terre qui nous
le fournissent les sciences du climat
les référentiels à un temps humain qui
est de l'ordre du million d'années ou de
milliers d'années là encore on s'est
sciences nous donnent des éléments et
puis en fait en combinant des modèles
d'évolution la biodiversité avec les
prévisions climatiques qui sont
réalisées par les climatologues on
arrive à se projeter dans le moyen terme
ou dans le long terme alors la
difficulté c'est qu'en fait on arrive à
se projeter par rapport à l'existence
d'un système dans sa globalité ce qu'on
va avoir par exemple par exemple un
couvert forestier et ce qu'on va avoir
un marécage ou un trait de côte qui va
rester stable ou évolué et bien entendu
ces systèmes sont complexes donc on
arrive à avoir une vision d'un certain
nombre de services rendus par ces
systèmes
certains sont particulièrement
importants parce que ils sont le lieu
d'une activité économique fondamentale
ou ou d'un problème de santé
extrêmement important d'autres sont
moins visibles moins étudiées donc
effectivement dans nos décisions on
essaye de privilégier ou dans nos études
en tant que scientifique dans vos
décisions en tant que politique
évidemment on essaye tous de privilégier
une vision relativement globale afin
d'avoir une prévision assez claire sur
le futur
malheureusement il y a toujours des à
côté et des services rendus par la
biodiversité qui peuvent fluctuer en
fonction d'un certain nombre d'éléments
qui n'ont pas été étudiés qui sont pas
des éléments principaux des écosystèmes
donc ça c'est malheureusement une une
des conséquences de l'instabilité dans
laquelle nous sommes actuellement je
pense qu'il faut vraiment essayer de
garder raison et puis de regarder les
prévisions climatiques de les jumeler
avec les prévisions
concernant la biodiversité puis d'aller
de l'avant en essayant d'avoir une
vision malgré tout toujours systémique
de ne pas se focaliser sur une seule
espèce ou sur un seul organisme et
d'avoir une vision plus globale c'est
effectivement c'est c'est ça peut-être
comment dire relativement anxiogène
parce qu'on a l'impression de ne pas
posséder les clés du futur et de ne pas
être capable de garder une situation
dans laquelle on a l'impression
d'une certaine stabilité depuis un
certain nombre d'années
si je peux me permettre de le compléter
je pense l'enjeu l'enjeu et la
planification je pense toujours et esti
peut effrayer c'est c'est l'empilement
sans planification sans projection à des
échéances 2050
2070 de tout un tas d'emples politiques
publiques qui qui nous arrive on a un
sujet d'actualité qui était un sujet
majeur et c'était redit et à chaque
présentation c'est l'équilibre entre la
transition énergétique et la
préservation de la biodiversité le
climat ne doit pas prendre la main sur
le vivant et il faut respecter cet
équilibre pour réussir la mission qui
nous incombe à tous chacun dans nos
différentes fonctions de freiner cette
horizon de biodiversité mais surtout de
survie de l'humanité et je pense que
aujourd'hui et je vais parler d'un sujet
d'actualité qui est la loi
d'accélération de la transition
énergétique
on voit bien que le climat tout le monde
l'a appréhendé et que on est dans
aujourd'hui un effort important
des citoyens des parlementaires et du
gouvernement de manière générale sur
cette politique le la biodiversité est
un peu en reste si demain la transition
énergétique se fait au détriment de la
préservation de la biodiversité
j'aime cette phrase souvent dite parler
les militaires qui est mission réussie
100% échec mission réussie nous aurons
réussi à installer et à faire ce shift
du mythe énergétique mais nous aurons
une destruction telle du vivant que nous
n'aurons pas réussi finalement à un
progrès et à
réussir à éviter ce qui doit être une
menace et doit être une convention on va
parler d'un chat canal l'OMS dit quand
même l'OMS l'OMS dit c'est probablement
potentiellement la prochaine grande
pandémie au niveau mondial et nous
n'aurons pas réussi si nous faisons la
transition énergétique au détriment de
la diversité nous aurons pas réussi à
lutter contre les zones c'est un exemple
très concret donc il faut trouver le
juste équilibre oui la transition
énergétique si vous mettez la transition
énergétique
dans des coeurs de nature ils ont été
présentés qui sont des derniers bastions
qui permettent cette résistance qui
permettent des semer tout autour et donc
de continuer à maintenir un équilibre
fragilisé mais qui maintiennent un
équilibre la mission ne sera pas réussi
pour revenir sur à chaque année
je pense que l'enjeu de tous les travaux
de les uns les autres mènent c'est de
douter parce que la science est aussi ça
si on a des certitudes à l'instant T et
puis d'autres travaux viennent compléter
aujourd'hui ce qui est certain c'est que
on a une mission commune entre la
profession agricole et principalement de
l'élevage et toutes les personnes
s'intéressent à la protection de la
biodiversité à la vie phone notamment
cette mission elle doit être menée de
façon collégiale puisque aujourd'hui on
est dans une situation de Christelle 47
millions de volailles abattus en France
depuis depuis mai 2021 sans rupture ce
qui est important c'est que c'est une
grippe qui normalement n'a pas personne
à la grippe en plein été donc on a vécu
une année particulièrement chaude on
imaginait tous les épidémies nous
avaient prévu une rupture et à chaque
fois qu'on a une rupture le virus
redémarre en bas de l'échelle
aujourd'hui on n'est pas du tout dans
cette situation là c'est que le virus ne
sait pas du tout arrêté il a impacté
fortement l'élevage en Europe
et en France 78% soit pas moins 68% des
foyers épidémiaux de grippe aviaire à
l'échelle de l'Europe sont en France
aujourd'hui
vous voyez l'impact la France est
donc
évidemment
l'enjeu ce qui ressort le plus l'enjeu
c'est surtout que la grippe aviaire ne
devienne pas
n'envahissent pas notre environnement et
ne puisse pas être transmis par les
aérosols
vous savez parfois les virus sont-elles
pas capacité à diffuser qu'ils peuvent
se retrouver dans l'air il n'y a plus
besoin de mise en contact pour que la
maladie se propage ça ça serait le pire
scénario puisque on devrait vivre avec
et on n'aurait pas beaucoup de solutions
et alors là la filière on le voit déjà
aujourd'hui on nous annonce est une
réalité qui lui aura probablement des
pénuries en fin d'année pour les fêtes
de Noël sur tout un tas de volailles ou
de type de production puisque
nous avons une telle triste nous n'avons
pas la capacité d'alimenter les
bâtiments d'élevage qu'ils soient
ustensifs ou intensifs je ne fais pas de
de de partage en vos propos
qui donc ça c'est ce qu'on doit
absolument éviter une seule députée
le parlementaires c'est un enjeu très
fort et il y a plein d'épidémios très
très très précis là dessus il y a un
très
beaucoup de documentation un très beau
livre qui vient de sortir j'ai signé par
François moutoux sur les zones qui est
très très précis sur si je suis en train
de se passer
le
deuxième niveau c'est qu'on constate que
plus les oiseaux sont stressés
plus les oiseaux sont sensibles à chacun
ce qui veut dire en gros si je traduis
c'est plus oiseaux sont concentrés
parce qu'il y a un oiseau
dans la faune sauvage sont stressés au
moment où ils ont des petits ils doivent
trouver de la nourriture donc les
oiseaux ils ont des hormones de stress
très très forts c'est ce qui s'est passé
sur la clinique foot bassin dans le
traders cette année et les oiseaux
étaient tellement enfin avaient des taux
d'hormones très de stress non
liés à cette période que la population
était décimée en élevage c'est la même
chose plus les oiseaux sont concentrés
plus les oiseaux sont stressés et puis
les oiseaux sont sensibles à chacun
donc il va falloir desserrer
desserrer les élevages ça veut dire
changer de modèle et accompagner cette
transition il va falloir revenir à des
choses beaucoup plus extensif le plein
air n'est pas un problème on entend bien
en disant attention il y a des
connexions entre la faune sauvage à
travers le plein air le plein air et
vers quoi on doit tendre
[Musique]
de payer étrangers d'Asie en particulier
les apprécier
soit on casse ce système de production
et on l'éclate dans les territoires
il y a des démonstrateurs en cours
là-dessus mais voilà une réponse très
concrète et c'est surtout d'accompagner
la profession c'est pas de rejeter un
regard négatif sur un schéma versus un
autre
c'est de se dire voilà il y a des
possibilités voilà vers quoi on doit
tendre et je pense qu'il faut le faire
tous ensemble le ministre phéno a été
alerté n'ont plus le rencontrer
longuement sur la situation de la grippe
à bien faisant partie de la commission
nationale sur le siège à cette
commission nationale sur les zones mais
vraiment on est dans quelque chose qui
est devant nous et qui tu dois être pris
très au sérieux
je voulais pas qu'on dérive sur un
entretien sur la grippe aviaire mais il
y a quelque chose de très intéressant
dans votre réponse vous dites il
faudrait éclater le modèle et je
voudrais relever une
sorte de contradiction c'est comme ça
que j'ai compris j'ai pas dit que vous
avez été en contradiction entre deux
sujets que vous avez évoqué pour revenir
à notre sujet de biodiversité donc d'un
modèle agricole où on a concentré et
créer un virus qui va se traduire qu'il
peut se transmettre de manière très
dommageable à la biodiversité de de
migrateurs vous dites la solution c'est
de l'exploser pour que ça soit des zones
plus petites que les oiseaux soient
moins stressés et dans le même temps
tout à l'heure en parlant des énergies
renouvelables et du développement et la
transition énergétique vous nous disiez
oui il faut y arriver mais attention à
ne pas implanter justement des outils de
production de nouvelles formes d'énergie
de la transition énergétique dans des
territoires où ils ne sont pas pour pas
venir impacter la biodiversité et je
trouve que ces deux conclusions sont un
peu opposées parce que d'un côté on dit
les élevages je vais faire les mettre
partout et donc dans les endroits où il
peut y avoir une biodiversité à
préserver et c'est alors que alors qu'il
faudrait pas le faire pour les énergies
je pense c'est le député que l'élevage
peut être aujourd'hui il y a des la
planification la planification est
probablement une clé nous devons
installer un certain nombre de panneaux
photovoltaïques certains nombres
d'éoliennes à terre en mer dès qu'on
aura planifié c'est-à-dire de quoi on
parle on parle de combien d'hectares de
surface agricole utile de saü a condamné
parce qu'on va évidemment d'abord
exploiter on peut l'espérer
les milieux artificialisés mais on le
sait déjà ça ne suffira pas
à partir de là on planifie et on se met
d'accord sur des cartes des cartes de
chaleur on le fait déjà très bien sur
nos enjeux de souveraineté nous n'irions
pas menacer nos enjeux de souveraineté
nos bases militaires les fosses où nous
avons nos stations stratégiques pour
notre pays
on voit bien qu'il existe des cartes il
y a déjà des respects dans la
planification énergétique l'éolien en
mer on voit bien où il est installé
versus faut-il un potentiel technique
parce que s'il y a pas de vent
typiquement on peut pas l'installer mais
il y a aussi d'autres cartes de chaleur
qui sont prises en compte on voit bien
dans le projet Oléron pour ne citer que
celui-ci évidemment les enjeux de
souveraineté ont été pris en compte à
juste titre évidemment mais il n'y a pas
que des enjeux de souveraineté à court
terme et les enjeux de souveraineté à
long terme
les enjeux dont parle aujourd'hui sont
des enjeux de de
l'humanité et donc vont au moins je n'ai
pas de classification pas au moins aussi
importants que les enjeux à très court
terme que nous avons aujourd'hui donc la
planification et je crois qu'aujourd'hui
dans la planification il y a de la place
dans chaque territoire pour de l'élevage
en ustensile et nous devons revenir dans
un schéma de producteur ou consommateurs
et dans chaque territoire nous avons une
capacité d'accueil de l'élevage pour des
raccentiennes aussi mais pas que chez ma
permettant de nourrir nos concitoyens au
plus près des lieux où les gens vivent
qui
merci Florence donc moi je voulais
et justement parce qu'on est on était en
sujet mentionné qu'effectivement la
transition énergétique ne devait pas se
faire au détriment de la biodiversité
pour avoir défendu un amendement sur
notamment les frigides qui ne devraient
pas être concernés par l'installation de
de panneaux photovoltaïques puisque il
faudrait prendre en compte que ce sont
des lieux de libre-évolution des refuges
des habitats dont on méconnait justement
le rôle actuellement alors plus
spécifiquement sur ce que nous venons de
et merci à tous les intervenants c'est
vrai que les retraits du trait de côte
pause des problèmes colossaux et je
voulais demander si pendant le laps de
temps ou rien ne sera fait c'est à dire
la digue est ouverte là près de l'île
d'Oléron et donc une saninisation qui
est en train de se faire quel est le
laps de temps pendant lequel les
oiseaux migrateurs en quelque sorte
pourront continuer à être là
et la question c'est aussi est-ce que de
même ils vont pas essayer de coloniser
ou de d'aller sur un autre territoire
dans le même ordre d'idée par rapport à
la mise en charbonnière qui n'a pas
réussi à décaler est-ce que vous
constatez déjà que peut-être elle serait
en train de le faire et pourrait
s'adapter plus rapidement qu'on ne le
pense ensuite j'ai une autre question
parce que vous avez parlé donc monsieur
marteau des perruques des perruches
pardon et des perroquets or en région
parisienne il me semble alors je sais
pas si c'est exactement ces espèces là
mais est-ce qu'on les considère comme
espèce invasive ou pas parce qu'on
constate quand même qu'il y en a un
certain nombre et ensuite sur par
rapport aux incendies de Gironde et je
voudrais savoir si on a un état initial
de la perte de biodiversité puisqu'elle
est ce qu'elle est liée principalement à
la forêt je le pense est-ce que il y
aura du suivi
sur justement la la reconquête par les
espèces de ces lieux comment avec
d'autres espèces je suppose tous les
arbres ne sont plus là
si la question est pour moi sur la
biodiversité les forestiers Girondins
CRPF et les sylviculteurs
suivent la biodiversité de très près
d'idées très régulièrement je sais pas
si vous êtes d'accord monsieur marteau
mais on a on a vraiment avec la forêt de
production une biodiversité très
spécifique par exemple c'est sur
certaines sur ces les coupes rases on
trouve un papillon rare qui est le fadet
des leches qui n'existe que sur les
couperases par exemple donc il y a des
spécificités à la forêt de production et
la sylviculture suit d'assez près
finalement c'est
cette biodiversité du mois macroscopique
il y a quand même un changement
climatique sur le on l'a bien vu avec
les tourbières qui n'étaient plus des
tourbières mais des des Charmont presque
enfin bon il y a eu certainement là
dessus je suis pas sûr qu'il y a une
étude précise sur le sur la biodiversité
microscopique justement je vais me
poster une petite parenthèse je vous
laisse la parole aux intervenants
je vais juste mentionner parce que je
les connais du coup c'est une
association de naturaliste qui fait des
suivis qui s'appelle sister de nature
qui est basé au Haillan donc en dessous
de Bordeaux et qui fait justement des
suivis sur principalement des reptiles
et les amphibiens mais également sur les
invertébrés comme les papillons et pour
qui sont à pied d'oeuvre pour essayer de
suivre justement le devenir de ces
espèces dans ces dans ces milieux
dévastés
effectivement alors pour moi isolérant
pour répondre aux questions on a à peu
près 15 ans pour pour agir c'est à peu
près ça les cortèges les populations
d'oiseaux pour le moment ça date
c'est-à-dire recule au plus proche de la
côte donc ils ont abandonné ils ont
délaissé la zone où il y avait une
entrée de mer et donc sont encore dans
la partie qui la plus la plus terrestre
de de la réserve on a une quinzaine
d'années pour agir l'idée si
l'acquisition pouvait se faire elle se
ferait avec un modèle où on laisserait
l'exploitation agricole se faire un
rachat de terre immédiat donc une
compensation et puis une exploitation
pendant 8 à 10 ans et puis dans 8 à 10
ans on partirait sur un projet de
renaturation sur la partie des
migrations ce que l'on constate
changement climatique
accélère en partie les migrations alors
les oiseaux sont de plus en plus tardif
et rendre de plus en plus tôt la
difficulté de ces schémas
c'est que les oiseaux rentrent avec
moins d'énergie c'est à dire que les
oiseaux faut bien comprendre les oiseaux
font un énorme déplacement ils arrivent
sur leur quartier divers ils arrivent de
plus en plus tard parce que s'il est
fait partie c'est souvent être
dégradation climatique parce que leur
alimentation ne va pas être retrouvée
imaginez il y a moins d'insectes tout
simplement en été qu'en hiver donc les
oiseaux qui sont insectivores sont bien
obligés d'aller chercher des zones de
chaleur pour s'alimenter donc ces
oiseaux vont transiter de plus en plus
tard parce qu'on voit on a eu du
moustique des moustiques par exemple
abondants jusqu'au mois d'octobre vu la
température que nous avons vécu il y a
eu des martinets c'est une première en
France on a eu des martinets jusqu'au 23
24 octobre cette année alors que les
martiens normalement devraient être
parti en juillet
comme les printemps sont de plus en plus
tôt
et que ça se réchauffe partout également
en Afrique donc les oiseaux remontent
très vite et on arrive avec des oiseaux
qui ont des taux dans le grincement des
taux d'enzymes assez faibles
pour attaquer
une saison de reproduction qui est
extrêmement exigeante au-delà de vol
retour pour lancer leur reproduction
donc là on a une crainte
sur certaines espèces d'autres espèces
sont devenues opportunistes façon
opportuniste et elle ne mille plus c'est
le cas des cigognes vous disais que les
cigognes allaient mieux les cigognes
elles passent plus Gibraltar ou très peu
elle reste en Espagne au Portugal et
puis dès que les fois dès le mois de
janvier elles reviennent déjà
en métropole
qui concerne les perruches effectivement
en une perruche la perruche à collier
notamment qui est installé dans les
jardins parc de Sceaux entre autres
c'est une perruche qui a été qui était
qui existe aussi en Royaume-Uni qui
était lâché au départ qui s'adapte très
très bien les populations sont
abondantes elles rentrent en compétition
avec certaines espèces mais ça reste à
la marge il n'y a pas de programme du
tout sur cette espèce pour l'instant et
c'est non sujet on va dire je t'ai
différent de certaines autres espèces
d'oiseaux comme des canards les l'iris
matures rousse par exemple un canard
vient lui en compétition directement
avec l'erice mature à tête blanche tu es
une espèce européenne en grand danger
d'extinction donc là il y a des
programmes menés par les services de
l'État le FB en priorité et qui élimine
cette espèce c'est pas le cas de la
perruche à collier où il n'y a pas de
d'éléments précis on a aussi des
écureuils les écureuils qu'on a dans les
animaleries qui finalement sont lâchés
et puis viennent en compétition avec les
roues donc là aussi il y a des
programmes de suivi par le Muséum dans
un premier temps et puis s'il est avéré
qu'il y a des interactions négatives les
oiseaux sont limités sur les incendies
en Gironde il y a deux cas de figure il
y a la définition et je rentrerai pas
dans le débat de qu'est-ce qu'une forêt
et dans le cas des incendies en Gironde
il y a deux cas de figures très
différents il y a une très belle forêt
ancienne qui était ens pour le
département il y avait il y avait madame
la sénatrice effectivement c'est bien de
me reprendre il y avait une très belle
forêt qui aujourd'hui un impact notable
il y a des inventaires qui existent donc
on est en train de rassembler tous les
données naturalistes existent pour faire
un avant un après il y a aussi vous
l'avez dit c'est très vite reparti on
voit que la végétation repas
malheureusement les incendies se
succèdent à l'échelle de
mondiale dont tu commences à avoir pas
mal de publications sur comment les
choses s'opèrent aux États-Unis
notamment en outre-mer le parc de La
Réunion vous savez Parc national de la
Réunion classé au patrimoine mondial de
l'UNESCO a beaucoup brûlé à plusieurs
reprises le massif du Maïdo notamment
donc on commence à avoir des regards sur
comment la végétation reprend puisque là
il y a pas de possibilité de planter du
tout
la plaine des morts la pleine des morts
a brûlé il y a un an et demi donc il y a
là aussi tout un tas de suivi est un
impact fort sur la tortue d'Hermann donc
en Gironde on va bénéficier aussi de
toute cette évolution pour voir les
styles faut faire si et certains c'est
que
il faut éviter que ça se reproduise
malheureusement on voit bien que
le facteur risque augmente
il y a certainement les DFCI a augmenté
les dispositifs vraiment contre les
incendies
peuvent être renforcés et puis
certainement un choix des essences qui
rit de faire des bas mais il y aura
forcément une discussion de l'avenir de
la forêt il y a eu les assises de la
forêt
un vrai moment d'échange avec des
conclusions dans lesquelles on trouve
quand même beaucoup de solutions
proposées qui sont une belle un beau
guide j'ai envie de dire pour pour la
suite
je vous remercie
merci je avant de conclure on va laisser
la parole à Philippe bolo à moins que
d'autres
certains d'entre vous veuillent apporter
d'autres réponses
monsieur
sutoux Sautour si vous voulez apporter
des précisions sur tout ce que vous avez
entendu
rapidement la mésange au Pays-Bas c'est
important au Pays-Bas
j'ai pas vu de travaux qui indiquaient
qu'elle avait réussi à s'adapter en
revanche c'est pas ce sont pas les
populations toutes les populations les
enjeux Charbonnières qui sont impactés
en Grande-Bretagne la même
il a été fait ici à s'adapter parce que
le réchauffement qu'on a au printemps ne
se produit pas de la même manière ou
Pays-Bas et en Grande-Bretagne la hausse
de température est plus rapide en début
de printemps en Grande-Bretagne ce qui
fait que cette maison j'avais réussi à
s'adapter on voit pas de déclin de la
population à cet endroit-là donc on voit
une hétérogénéité des évolutions qui est
dues à une hétérogénéité des
modifications que l'on a à l'heure
actuelle
sur la forêt de les faux régirondine
on est en train de vivre du fait des
incendies quelque chose qui de mon point
de vue va être vécu à l'échelle d'autres
territoires et dans d'autres contextes
et qui va concerner la manière dont on
considère l'environnement naturel entre
guillemets que l'on a autour de nous les
débats que l'on a à l'heure actuelle
dans la région je suis pas spécialiste
de la forêt mais bon je travaille avec
des collègues qui sont sur ce sujet là
il y a beaucoup de débats à l'heure
actuelle pour savoir si on plante du
pain pour faire simple ou une autre la
puissance qu'on va exploiter ou bien si
on laisse
redémarrer une forêt de manière
naturelle on va dire avec des statuts de
forêt avant qu'elle brûle qui était pour
certaines très diversifiées c'est la
forêt qu'on avait en arrière de la Lune
du Pilat et d'autres qui étaient des
forêts exploités
pas loin de ses premières forêt et puis
à d'autres endroits qui ont brûlé aussi
donc il y a des débats sur ce sujet là à
l'heure actuelle évidemment les
objectifs
recherchés sont pas les mêmes et si
jamais on replante quelle essence on
replantes donc là il y a aussi une
complexité ça renvoie aussi aux
questions de ce que l'on considère comme
étant une forêt moins vulnérable du
point de vue du risque incendie parce
que ce risque là effectivement il a sa
croître et donc il va falloir qu'on
trouve les moyens d'adapter nos forêts
une forêt naturelle est-ce que c'est une
forêt dans laquelle on fait quand même
des pare-feu par exemple pour faire très
simple
et puis ça questionne aussi et il y a
des travaux qui commencent sur le sujet
ça questionne aussi la proximité des
habitats et de la forêt on a un habitat
très dispersé ici mais aussi à d'autres
endroits avec une proximité immédiate de
la forêt et dans certaines
agglomérations dont je parle de
l'habitat isolée ici mais dans certaines
agglomérations on a des forêts qui sont
à proximité médias des agglomérations
petits agglomérations ça pose question
aussi donc
malheureusement ces phénomènes se sont
produits mais ça nous amène à poser des
questions à nous poser des questions sur
notre place par rapport à cet
environnement qui est en train de
changer alors je fais de manière
accélérée parce qu'on a eu ces incendies
mais je pense que ce sont des questions
qu'on va devoir se poser à beaucoup
d'autres endroits et pas forcément des
points de vue des assemblées
merci beaucoup si quelqu'un veut
rajouter quelque chose Philippot merci
une question très rapide vous avez tous
entendu parler comme moi de du projet
Nora link l'entreprise d'Elon musk qui
part du principe que le maintien de la
biodiversité passe par une nouvelle
diversité l'utilisation d'ADN d'espèces
disparue et c'est un sujet qu'on a peut
évoqué c'est que comment faut-il
considérer les banques d'ADN pour dans
cette perspective de garder la mémoire
de la biodiversité qu'on aurait perdu
alors effectivement il y a une des
techniques de préservation qui existent
en sciences depuis pas mal de décennies
qui sont passés autrefois par les grands
musées d'histoire naturelle qui
continuent d'ailleurs à
remplir cette mission et puis qui sont
complétés aujourd'hui par toutes sortes
d'informations à commencer par des
informations génomiques alors ce sont
des informations qui sont utilisées à
beaucoup d'égards d'abord dans un but de
recherche scientifique général de
comprendre
l'origine et puis les mécanismes qui
gouvernent
la génération de cette diversité comment
les espèces apparaissent comment elles
s'adapte etc
alors ces banques de données peuvent
être aussi effectivement utilisées à
d'autres égards d'ailleurs ça pose un
problème particulier de négociation
actuellement dans le cadre de la
Convention sur la diversité biologique
ce que vous savez que cette convention à
trois piliers thématiques la
conservation la gestion durable et le
partage des avantages il partage des
avantages jusqu'à présent c'était une
question qui était liée à ce que l'on
appelait des ressources génétiques et
donc les différents pays détenteurs de
biodiversité en fait demandaient que les
avantages qui soient liés aux
connaissances qu'on acquiert sur cette
diversité soit en fait partager dans
leurs avantages matériels par exemple si
on séquence un gène qui a une utilité
particulière éventuellement qu'on dépose
un brevet qu'on exploite son brevet au
fait que les populations et notamment
les savoir traditionnels qui ont permis
à l'origine cette découverte puisse être
rétribuée aujourd'hui en fait les études
génomiques justement sont concerné
commence à concerner par cette question
il y a une négociation en cours à ce
sujet depuis plusieurs années qui va
continuer à la COP15 à Montréal et qui
est particulièrement importante sur le
plan juridique et puis sur le plan légal
qui menace d'un côté la science ouverte
c'est-à-dire que certaines données
pourraient pu être disponible pour tout
un chacun y compris les scientifiques
puis l'autre côté qui essaye de réguler
malgré tout une utilisation un peu
sauvage de données scientifiques qui
pourraient utiliser par certains groupes
industriels alors le problème on le voit
de la biodiversité des complexes on est
devant des systèmes qui évoluent déjà
qui ont leur propre dynamique vient
superposer à ces dynamiques nos
activités des changements globaux
d'environnement comme le changement
climatique que nous avons nous-même créé
on a déjà du mal à déterminer des
trajectoires à l'échelle de la décennie
ou du siècle en utilisant des modèles
prévisionnels climatiques qui sont
connectés à des modèles prévisionnels
sur les écosystèmes
moi j'aurais tendance à dire quelquefois
que l'introduction de nouveaux joueurs
dans la partie c'est à dire de nouveaux
joueurs de nouvelles espèces ou
d'espèces qui ont été modifiées
génétiquement en fait consiste tu pas
forcément un grand avantage et au
contraire
apporte à certains noms de risque alors
sans être pour autant voilà exagérément
timide ou apeuré il y a deux éléments
potentiels dont il faut se rappeler
quand on introduit des espèces qui ont
été modifiées soit par forçage soit par
une modification génétique plus
classique en fait on a deux risques
différents un risque déjà de mal
adaptation c'est à dire que la plupart
du temps les organismes modifiants ont
été modifiés au laboratoire quand ils
sont lâchés dans le milieu naturel on
s'aperçoit que ils n'ont pas une grande
viabilité et au bout de quelques temps
en fait
les modifications qui sont apportées sur
contre sélectionnées et c'est par
exemple le cas par exemple du maïs Bt un
maïs qui produit une toxine contre des
ravageurs en fait on s'aperçoit que il y
a des ravageurs qui deviennent très vite
résistants contre cette toxine et puis
USB lui-même n'a pas une productivité
extraordinaire donc finalement ça
constitue pas une avancée importante
donc au plan opérationnel souvent c'est
modifications n'apportent pas grand
chose en termes par exemple de
production alimentaire ou d'autres
d'autres avantages puis d'autres parts
et un autre élément qui ce qu'on appelle
la pollution génétique à partir du
moment où on introduit des éléments
nouveaux dans un patrimoine génétique au
relâche ces espèces dans le milieu
naturel si ces espèces sont des
apparentés qui se trouvent également
dans le milieu naturel il peut y avoir
transfert de ces gènes introduits de ces
systèmes modifié à d'autres espèces
c'est le cas par exemple
de certaines espèces de plantes
cultivées par exemple pour des gènes de
résistance à certains herbicides
systémiques et là on se trouve devant
des problématiques
très ennuyeuses actuellement par exemple
on fait face à multiplication des
résistances aux herbicides chez
certaines adventices qui menacent les
cultures précisément parce qu'on a intro
des modifications génétiques dans des
plantes cultivées qui étaient censés
leur permettre d'être cultivés grâce à
l'aide d'herbicides systémique donc
voilà c'est c'est il y a une sorte de
principe de précaution qu'il faut
arriver à utiliser dans ces cas-là de
manière dans une situation qui est déjà
complexe qui est déjà dont un a déjà du
mal à mesurer un potentiel d'évolution
pour prendre de bonnes décisions ne pas
introduire des données supplémentaires
effectivement il y a des données
génomiques qui sont produites en grand
nombre maintenant grâce à l'amélioration
des méthodes en biologie moléculaire
elles sont extrêmement intéressantes à
utiliser pour des problématiques de
sciences et pour des problématiques
aussi d'adaptation par exemple pour
comprendre le potentiel pour certaines
espèces sur s'adapter au changement
environnementaux pour autant modifier le
génome des espèces c'est les introduire
le milieu naturel jusqu'à présent on n'a
pas grand intérêt et présente surtout un
certain nombre de désavantages
merci beaucoup est-ce que vous avez
quelque chose à rajouter est-ce qu'on a
fait le
je pense que cette table ronde
passionnante nous a
c'est difficile de synthétiser le une
table ronde comme ça mais je pense que
le réchauffement climatique on l'a
compris n'est pas le seul le seul enjeu
la surpopulation mondiale va forcément
aboutir à des à des dérives des
compétitions
les pollutions en particulier du
plastique que connaît particulièrement
notre collègue Angèle Préville la
mondialisation de transport d'espèces
tout ça tout ça intervient mais le
l'homme est résilient doit essayer de
trouver des moyens madame Monet vous en
avez parlé la nature la vie dans la
nature nous est indispensable est
indispensable à notre survie j'en suis
persuadé quand je quitte Paris pour
revenir chez moi en Gironde c'est c'est
vital je suis en train de lire un
livre sur la nostalgie la nostalgie
jusqu'au 19e siècle était une maladie
qui a été décrite à partir de
à partir de 1650 à peu près et qui était
une maladie de l'exil
nous notre nostalgie elle risque d'être
la nostalgie de l'environnement naturel
qui est le nôtre c'est c'est vraiment à
ça que je pense on a aussi parlé de nos
télomères de ceux des huîtres
finalement nous avons fait avec Bernard
jaumier un rapport sur la sur la
médecine environnementale ouais enfin
bon finalement
tout est lié et pour terminer sur un sur
quelque chose d'un peu plus comment dire
positif
hier nous avions avec le groupe Vinet 20
donc je fais partie
le tout ce qui concerne les espèces
résistantes comment est-ce qu'on va
continuer à faire du vin malgré le
réchauffement climatique le vignoble
c'est aussi de la biodiversité qu'elle
cépage qu'elle cépage va-t-on
privilégier faut-il effectivement faire
attention à ne pas utiliser de de génome
modifiés et plutôt introduire
réintroduire des espèces anciennes qui
étaient déjà peut-être sur notre
territoire le filocéra étant passé par
là il y a des tas de sujets et et
si on veut pouvoir consommer un vin qui
ne soit pas
trop dosé en degré qui reste à l'échelle
de l'homme et qui reste agréable il faut
se poser toutes ces questions et si je
l'occasion de faire déguster des espèces
de
expérimental sur
des pages bordelais adaptées adaptée au
climat actuel je le ferai avec plaisir
monsieur le Président
je voudrais tout d'abord remercier
l'ensemble de nos intervenants de ce
matin pour la pertinence dans leur
domaine à respectifs scientifiques et
puis associatif pour pour la Ligue des
protection des
oiseaux qui je le dis ici fait un
travail remarquable sur l'ensemble du
territoire et c'est aussi à double titre
en tant que président de l'office mais
aussi en tant que député de la Vendée
que j'ai intérêt tout particulier à une
attache à vous entendre toutes et tous
ce matin on a parlé de notamment la
grippe aviaire qui touche
particulièrement ce département au vu de
la forte concentration d'élevage
au vu également effectivement de l'enjeu
on l'a vu sur le sur l'estuaire de la
Gironde mais aussi un certain nombre de
bassins de l'Arc Atlantique et
d'ailleurs et notamment en ce qui
concerne la baie de l'Aiguillon vous
avez parlé tout à l'heure chez marteau
de de
la belle henriette et évidemment de tous
ces enjeux en termes de préservation de
et de politique en ce qui concerne les
réserves naturelles il y aura d'ailleurs
à ce sujet un certain nombre de d'enjeux
à la fois
politique qui vont qui vont arriver
environnementaux je pense notamment à
l'annonce de la secrétaire d'État à la
biodiversité concernant un onzième parc
national labellisés qui fait beaucoup
parler aujourd'hui on attend évidemment
aussi l'expertise de de la Ligue de pour
la protection des oiseaux sur le sur le
sujet bien évidemment
sur les sur OK également sur les huîtres
c'est un sujet qu'on peut être
complètement passionnant la
congéliculture australiculture avec
évidemment cette impératif aussi de
protection et de maintien de la
biodiversité dans ces espaces bref
on le voit c'est ce sont des enjeux et
des conséquences qui sont énormes et qui
sont dans notre quotidien ce que je
voudrais simplement
dire pour conclure
c'est que justement cette vision de la
nostalgie dont un rapporteur
évoqué à l'instant
je crois que c'est une piste qui
est assez dangereuse
parce qu'elle conduirait finalement à
d'abord à faire fi de la réalité
à la fois de ce qu'est la biodiversité
et notamment de la réalité dynamique
dont
Monsieur Grandcolas vous vous évoquez
tout à l'heure
et parce que au final
c'est ce climat d'anxiété dont Gérard
Longuet évoqué également dans son propos
liminaire ce climat d'anxiété qui
finalement nous conduirait à
ne pas agir dans dans notre
individualité je crois au contraire que
et comme vous le faites vous l'avez tous
fait dans vos interventions ce matin
c'est plutôt regarder les enjeux qui
sont devant nous regarder également à la
fois ces pistes de de réflexion et
scientifique et politique qu'on peut
collectivement mettre en place
pour que nos concitoyens aussi dans leur
choix individuel qui seront faits pour
lesquelles
nous sommes évidemment
elles vont toujours des difficultés à et
c'est bien normal puisque le principe de
liberté
prévôt
politique ne peut pas contraindre
absolument les choix individuels qui
sont faits et je crois qu'il y a un vrai
enjeu et ça a été ça a été dit lors de
cette
lors de cette audition ce matin un vrai
enjeu d'éducation à poursuivre notamment
dans la culture scientifique et vraiment
encore une fois je me retourne vers tous
les tous les chercheurs qui sont là ce
matin tous ceux qui nous écouteront
également on compte énormément sur vous
vous savez que le Parlement notamment
dans le cadre de la loi de programmation
de la recherche à énormément
fléchés d'investissement nouveau sur la
diffusion de la culture et de la
médiation scientifique je 3
véritablement que au-delà de la prise de
conscience politique générale qui est
faite aujourd'hui il y a un vrai enjeu
justement aussi pour bien cibler à la
fois les problématiques mais surtout les
solutions qui pourront être apportées
par les notes générations et les futurs
générations et c'est pourquoi cette
cette impérative de médiation
scientifique que nous tenons à faire
également ici au sein de l'Office
parlementaire d'évaluation des choses
scientifiques et technologiques nous
paraît fondamental et je sais qu'il est
également pour vous en tout cas on
tâchera et je sais que la rapporteur
aura véritablement cette cette vision
là lors de des conclusions de de son
rapport de pouvoir aussi faire en sorte
que nous puissions plus largement avoir
cette diffusion de de nos travaux
diffusion de surtout de vos travaux pour
qu'ils soient mieux bien compris de nos
concitoyens et pour que à la fois dans
les choix collectifs que nous prenons
politiquement et les choix individuels
de l'ensemble de nos concitoyens qu'ils
puissent converger vers cette lutte à
l'effectible pour la préservation de la
biodiversité on l'a compris en tout cas
encore une fois ce matin dont les
conséquences humaines
aussi bien que environnemental
sont annoncés et vont être très
difficiles à gérer c'est pourquoi on
tenait à vous remercier pour cet
éclairage évidemment nous aurons à coeur
de poursuivre ce cycle encore une fois
il y a effectivement des enjeux la COP
15 biodiversité qui va arriver avec des
travaux également à l'office qui sont en
cours en ce moment pour qu'on puisse
être nous aussi parlementaire acteur aux
côtés de la science
et surtout
qu'on puisse être des
facilitateurs de la science merci à vous
merci beaucoup
je lève la séance